I'm Fred no band
Invisible band Freaky ghost band Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah
Yeah, yeah Yeah Hello Welcome
Do you see What is next to me?
perceive this it's quite quiet right now because uh it's in
like this uh i call it trailer mode i don't know if it has
another fort whatever it's my apache slot yippee oh my gosh
my my stuff is kind of all over the place so attract mode
demo mode that sounds like the most sense but i kind of like
attract mode attract mode wait that's real attract mode is a
actual phrase i've never heard that before it's just like oh
my gosh thank you it's like uh how to say it's like uh she
gives you a little like if she flashes a little ankle like
don't you want to try my wears
me actually this is really strange because because i don't
think before i ever did a hand cam because you know for me
it's a little difficult as a ghost but i got some special
gloves thank you i know almost nothing about the patchy slot
other than the cut scenes and it playing at a convention
once this is a whole new and unique experience i know I'm so
excited um paid actor no no I got some ghost gloves because
usually if you see like if I'm trying to show you my hands
on on stream you won't be able to see you know because I'm a
ghost like it's a see-through but I got these like special
ghost gloves that kind of hold my ectoplasm in so we'll be
A-OK baby yuppie um also I will need to test some audio
stuff with you guys.
I want your opinions because there are three.
Thank you for the donations, thank you, thank you, thank
you, thank you.
Pachinko.
There are three sound options that we can get for you guys
hearing the machine itself.
Oh my gosh, I'm so nervous.
Thank you.
Thank you guys for the tono so much.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
The machine looks so cool.
It's very cool.
Honestly, if anything, it just looks amazing, right?
Like it's just so well and so, so well.
It's so well.
It's so pretty.
It's so good.
It's not good.
It's just, you know.
Even without playing it, this thing's rad.
I know, right?
like this the details on it are kind of insane also it's
really cool because let me show you like this hold on i'm
waiting for it to light back up i'm sorry about the lighting
um i have it will get better i wanted to make sure you could
see uh the the of course the um the slots themselves uh it
was a little tricky i had to go through a couple different
cameras um i tried to see if there was a way output the
screen itself but also then you wouldn't be able to see the
slots so we kind of had to have it in camera mode like this
I current I got my I got my stop talking about my hand I
yeah I what was I saying oh my gosh you guys made me forget
um um what was I saying Oh, I got my GoPro actually to work
as like a webcam and it has the best kind of...
Oh my gosh.
It's so good.
I screamed.
Don't scream.
Boo.
Thank you.
Almost too spooky to handle.
Real, real ghost activity.
This is actually...
I tricked you guys.
This is a real phasmophobia stream.
Oh my gosh.
But yeah, so sorry that it is like a camera like this.
I wish that I could output, maybe in the future I can find a
way to do it if I become so technically literate.
But again, of course we're wanting to see the slots
themselves too.
Also just, I don't know if I can, if there's anything like
legally like, you know, I'm Obviously, this is a gambling
machine, but I will not be paying any money as I have this
nifty button right here that...
Oh, oh gosh, it started.
That if I press it, it inputs credits for me.
So I'm also sorry there is a slight flicker.
I know I'm apologizing so much, but I really...
I did my best to, like, put up...
put the optimal setup for your enjoyment.
Also, look at this.
This is one big screen.
Isn't that crazy?
It's one huge screen.
It's so awesome.
Yeah!
I will be picking up the camera and kind of like zooming in
on little bits too because there's some stuff that like
happens in here that you can only really see if um oh my god
the music is so awesome if like you're you know on top of it
so if since you can't really see it with the webcam oh you
see you can see him just a little bit this is what it looks
like okay my my perspective is a little cropped also for
people who are just like this is pachinko no this is patchy
slot because it's not pachinko it won't be like you know
what i mean like it won't be all the little balls falling
and being noisy and annoying no it's actually quite quiet
which is i mean you could probably can barely hear it right
now which brings me to my next thank you thank you i can't
believe we kidnapped a cute girl to represent you mint no i
swear this is a ghostly hand ectoplasm gloves on or
ectoplasm uh what's the word
enhance kubuki chopachinko ASMR no thank you okay so we have
three options for your listening pleasure one is just like
how it is now right now there's like no music i will let's
see let's uh let's Let's add some cash money up in here.
You can probably barely hear it.
Barely, barely, barely hear it.
I'm just going to put in a ton.
Yeah, I simp.
Okay, we maxed that out.
So, I'll also give you a kind of a rundown of a little bit
of this stuff.
Oh, one thing you can't see is right here.
My hand, hello.
On the side here, this is, it's kind of hard to see because
I have my lights out so you can see the screen better.
but this is like a a walkie talkie kind of thing and then on
the side there's like a light up exclamation point it's so
cute anyway okay yeah you can hear it okay so this is a
little button to control a menu the menu kind of changes uh
how to say the it changes um
you can change there's some points where um the they'll like
say like push button one push button two push button three
and someone will be like manna ka megi he daddy and uh you
can change the voice you can change it to like snake or the
boss or signant oh my gosh thank you for the ari guadalardo
arigado chum thank you you're the reason why i'm getting
into metal gear now so i'm really excited thank you so much
but there's also you can change the mode so there's like
advanced mode normal mode and classic mode i honestly i have
no idea the difference they are all difficult i have no idea
i have no idea um of course we have our little lever here we
have the payout button right here and of course our our
clicky clacky buttons so let's try all right oh my god wow
great start oh my gosh it doesn't just look so good though
oh my god snake looks so awesome okay i'm gonna keep going
until something oh okay we got spotted kind of so this is a
good point to test the audio i'd say because you can hear
also i can't let this let it run for too long just right now
because something kind of cool happens if you let the slots
keep going keep going but this is a good point to test the
audio so so this is the first audio it's really mostly it's
just my regular mic but I do have another mic set up over
here so you can hear the game a little bit better but if I
play my mic and this mic at the same obviously there's gonna
be an echo in my voice we can't hear the audio I know I know
it's it's not on right now thank you but if I have only this
mic on it kind of sounds like an Xbox mic so I'm gonna turn
on this mic now so you can hear how is that it's probably
you can hear my voice twice but if it doesn't bother you
guys we can keep it because obviously I want you guys to
hear my voice.
It's loud?
I'm so sorry.
It's kind of spooky.
And then if I turn off my mic and I only have...
It's still loud?
Sorry, sorry.
If I only have this mic on, I sound like I'm playing Xbox
Call of Duty.
So which one would you guys prefer?
I'm going to put up a poll actually.
That'll help me the most I think.
So, oh, which mic?
Which?
Mint only?
Mint and Pachinko.
Xbox mic.
um the way i actually it's it's kind of funny it's kind of
funny um how this is actually the webcam mic i intended on
having like oh oh see see ah the sorrow comes and he's just
like he says stop the reel stop is from spinning it's so
spooky i love it um but uh the this is actually a webcam I
intended on having like a webcam kind of like giving a more
close-up image but in the end my webcam was kind of shit so
it it just didn't do a good quality so I'm really sorry but
this is the best I could do in what I had yeah that was cool
right it's so cool okay so we we managed to escape now you
are going to see all of this a lot this this cut these cut
scenes you are going to see so many times and I bet you are
I bet you we're gonna see a bunny oh never mind oh the tree
was in the way Wow I was wrong I saw a bunny so many times
okay we're walking down this is what I mean that not a lot
happens in this game also I see that the result is mint and
pachinko double okay so we're gonna keep it like this I'm so
sorry if it's distracting for some of you guys but
Dang, lost the shot.
Yeah, the tree was in the way is what he said.
Yeah, the tree was in the way.
So we're gonna bet, we're gonna do this, we're walking down
the pathway.
A whole lot of nothing is going on.
Gosh, oh my gosh, what is it?
What could it be?
It's gonna be, I don't know.
A chance!
Yeah, it's a chance!
Oh my gosh, he gave me a chance, you guys.
Oh, we upgraded to blue!
I have no idea what that means.
Our loot box in Metal Gear, can you imagine?
Maybe this.
Oh, pasha!
Oh, dang.
Of course the one time, look at that.
Isn't it so cool?
Gosh, it's...
Oh!
Okay, place your bets, everyone.
What do you think we're going to get?
I think we're going to get a fork.
What do you think you're gonna get?
What do you think?
The screen broke.
I know it's so cool, right?
A cigar or ration?
I think we're gonna get a fork But if we get a ration that
would be pretty awesome.
I'll okay.
I don't all the times I've played this I've only I'll give
you guys a clue.
I've only gotten a fork and a ration before.
I have never gotten a cigar or an Ammunition box or a key or
the mystery ever so streamer luck.
Come on Streamer luck.
Come on streamers luck.
Oh We got a fork.
That's okay.
Next time.
Sokolov!
He's gonna say,
What?
Oh my god.
I'm breaking all expectations today.
It's a fork!
Let's go, baby!
We upgraded the gold!
I have no idea what that means.
Oh.
Oh my god, are we gonna, oh, wait, now we will see the
bunny, I think.
What?
Oh my god, what is going on?
No way!
Oh my god, oh, oh, oh, oh, did you see that glitch?
Thank you for the don't know!
Based on lore, would this ghastly form be akin to venish,
venish?
Ooh, the Venish.
Venom punished steak or big boss.
So I'm absolutely jealous you got your hands on such a
legendary trophy.
I know some people...
Good!
What does that mean?
I know some people have wondered how much this cost me.
Oh!
Yes!
Hutton!
We can continue!
you guys we can continue to the next area now these parts
are so cute because like okay you'll see here we go the
progress camouflage is a mystery oh my gosh Mike peeking oh
okay I'm gonna I'm gonna turn down just a little bit more
I'm so sorry this is still experimental I was trying okay oh
wait so we're trying to So cool, I have it.
Ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh.
Okay, next.
Good, good.
The music is so cute.
And continue, next.
Nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Okay, okay.
Wait, why are we suddenly inside the building?
Okay.
Last game!
Oh my gosh, why?
It's on fire!
I'll be honest, I have never seen this.
Get him, get him, Asala!
We're gonna do it!
Oh my god, no!
Wait, where's Trump?
We're getting back to his mission already?
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god!
Maybe.
Okay, let's go save Sokolov, I guess.
Sokolov, I guess.
Sokolov, real!
Okay, I don't think you can choose a guy, I think it just
kind of...
We're just gonna attack him.
Alright.
Ta-ta, ta-ta, ta-ta.
Okay, come on, Snake.
Take his butt down!
Great!
Oh my god, it's so cute.
I love Tiny Paramedic.
She's so precious.
Now, hopefully, okay, so if we do all of this well, if we
complete this virtuous mission well, we'll get the actual
cutscenes of the game, which is what I really want to show
you guys.
So, thank you for the dodge.
Thank you!
Okay, took that guy down.
Easy peasy, great.
Come on.
Oh my god!
He's got the knife.
Oh, okay.
Hold on.
Let's try again.
The timing was not right.
Mike desynced.
Oh, I'm so sorry.
I'm doing my best, you guys.
Okay, here we go.
Here we go.
Jump.
Make his butt down.
Oh, not that way.
Get better at gambling.
Good.
Okay, we at least made it.
Yes.
Chats it up.
Oh, it's fine.
There is a button here.
I'm not quite sure what it's for.
It does say push, but I don't know ever when to push it.
Oh no!
So loud!
Too!
Thank you!
You've even been to surprise by the patchy slack going off
script.
There's a lot.
Oh, I have to add more credits.
We've already spent this.
It goes up to 50 credits.
And we've already spent them.
Isn't that crazy?
I don't know actually how much.
I don't know actually how much it cost to play this.
Does anyone have any better insight?
Oh, I always fail this, you guys.
I always fail this.
$20 per credit.
Does the Pachinko machine come with some sort of developer
mode that lets you automatically get alternate scenes?
If it does, I don't...
I don't know.
You guys, my luck is coming in real clutch here.
Cutie looks...
Okay.
Come on, Snake.
Don't miss.
Oh, damn.
I told you guys.
I'm sorry.
I think now we have to go back to the very beginning.
No?
Yeah.
Okay.
Yep.
We're back at the very beginning.
Your eyes jump.
Thank you.
There is... So basically...
when I came when I was setting up yesterday for this I did
have to like I did have to kind of do some stuff because
when I hadn't turned it on in the two months that I was gone
like there's like a thing with the RAM I had to like clear
the RAM and like there's like a system key and then I press
a reset button and turn the system key off And it was like
this whole thing.
Oh, oh, sorry.
I still have money.
Oh, it sucks that we went back to the beginning.
I want to hopefully, there's two things I want to show.
First is a boss fight, whichever boss we can get.
And second is the, if we can get big boss mode.
Actually, I do want to show.
There we go.
I do want to show the menu too if I have a chance.
Oh!
Oh no no!
We'll take this guy down.
We'll take him down.
Oh!
Nice!
Your soup!
So your amount of effort you went through to stream, this is
so funny.
What do you mean?
I paid for Streamlabs Pro to make you look at my Oshi stuff.
Wait, I didn't- I missed it!
Oh, here we go.
So this is the menu that I was talking about earlier.
So this is like the kind of mode.
There's classic, normal, advanced.
We're just on normal.
Yeah.
Oh, no.
Oh, okay.
Just kidding.
I can't show you the other things now.
I can't show you the other.
Well, next time.
Oh, oh.
Here we go.
Okay.
This is the, um, say Navi Custom, is the Navigator.
So you can have Major Zero.
You can have, oh, I thought there was Siggint, but I think I
remembered Siggint just because he's here.
You can't actually have him talking for you.
But obviously Snake, Asala and the boss.
I think I had it set to the boss, but who do you guys want?
I don't think we've heard, we haven't heard, them doing the
yeah but which one do you guys want Ocelot?
Ocelot?
I saw Ocelot the most I think he sounds so goofy
isn't it just the game just looks so beautiful also little
snake down here will sometimes like be dressed up different
sometimes he'll have his shirt off
Sometimes...
Sometimes he'll be wearing a beret, the tree was in the...
Oh!
We're snow!
I don't know what this is.
I have no idea.
I don't know at all.
I think it helps when you go into like the virtuous mission
and stuff.
Oh!
Hi, paramedic!
Oh my gosh!
Oh!
the lighting oh that was kind of crazy um this is this is
peak for here i'm gonna make a pin real quick about uh about
my mic situation there is double mic so um you can hear the
game better without me sounding like i on an xbox is it
peaking so much though um yeah mention that we voted for i
will the chat voted it was the best option sorry if it's
weird lumal it's not peaking that much okay pin message just
close echo okay yeah i'm so sorry about it i i was that's i
was very like i was very much like i don't know which option
to choose like I want you guys to be able to hear me better,
but also hear the game so clearly as well, too.
Okay, these guys are...
Do something.
Sorry, sorry, Soru!
I'm gonna stop it!
Hold on!
Oh, they're so stupid.
We're just crashed behind a tree.
These guys are idiots.
Oh, it's glitching again.
Okay, interesting, interesting.
Oh.
Um...
Yours.
Oh!
Tiger Stripe!
Okay, nice.
I wonder when we'll see the body.
I have been given the gift of prophecy.
Thank you for the donuts!
Oh, I was going to say earlier, I keep forgetting, um, wait,
former slot mathematician here, you should get more
cutscenes if you bet max credits and max, I don't know, oh,
I do max bet every time, and I'll just add all the credits.
Oh, we're going to shoot this guy, we're going to shoot this
guy this time, or we're going to throw, um, Something to
distract him.
Oh!
Oh, my gosh!
Streamer, the...
Pichu!
Oh.
Oh, okay.
Why does it...
Every time that I try to make the noise, it doesn't work.
Um...
This is the one where he beats up the barrel!
Trans!
We got to see Vulcan!
Vulcan looks so good in this game, it's crazy.
Um, sorry, I keep feeling distracted, what I want to say.
Um, people might be wondering how much this cost me.
Usually, I know where I yellow.
Usually, I don't like to, you know, I'm not trying to, I
don't want to, like, brag.
I'm not trying to brag or anything.
Do we get to see Rykov?
Rykov is here, yes.
see him sometimes um but it was about with shipping with
shipping it was about um i can't remember exactly i think it
was about like 1400 us dollars so some people think like
it's a correct like i mean that is a lot of money don't get
me wrong but like it is not maybe what some people think and
to be fair like this thing i mean it's very nice so
oh oh oh oh oh oh okay we get to progress you guys some i
don't know why i don't know why we're progressing but
something happened
the progress camouflage is still a mystery that's okay also
i love down here like the it's like the title screen it just
looks so cool okay we're in a different place this time
cheaper than my pc yeah like it is like you know less
expensive than some gaming pc so okay doing so well sorry i
get so used to just like So, I gotta build up a little
suspense, right?
Next.
What?
I don't even finish.
No way.
I didn't even get...
I didn't even...
The game is rigged!
Uh-oh.
warning or you can get caught by the way and then there's
like a up here there will be like the countdown and
everything push out why every time
back to blue yeah back to blue oh see i told you guys we
would be seeing this cut scene a whole lot oh oh oh oh my
gosh is there something inside Please don't get crushed.
Please.
Oh my god, it's my destiny to be in the boss!
Oh, come on.
I don't know.
Oh.
We stepped on a stick.
Oh, we are so suspicious.
Who?
Oh my gosh.
It's okay.
Everybody?
Calm down.
I like how we're like non-lethal mode the whole time
never thought I would watch slots I like how he calls them
annoying guys this is like men don't do it he's burning the
papers oh my gosh oh we're green now we're green I don't
know what that means.
They are annoying.
Yeah, they're extremely annoying.
Sagan!
We're red now!
I don't know what that means.
Oh, oh come on, come on, come on.
Come on, come on, come on.
Come on!
Loop boxes.
Hate me.
Oh, Sokolov's still burning those papers.
Nanda korewa.
If none of this makes sense to you guys, it doesn't make
sense to me either.
I have no idea how this works.
I have tried looking up like...
Like, if you get this combination, if you get this
combination, but like...
I don't know.
Triple blue seems common.
What?
Paramedic.
She's looking at her body again, you know?
They don't make walkthroughs for slot machines.
This is the walkthrough for anyone else who owns a Metal
Gear Solid Apache slot machine.
We're seeing these guys quite often though.
Just keep putting in credits.
Okay, okay, what do you guys think we're gonna get this
time?
Thank you!
Gotta feed the patchy slot.
Wait, okay.
Which do you guys think we're gonna get?
Fork?
Key?
Key!
Oh, ma ma da na.
We gotta ration!
Get you guys.
Oh?
Another chance at the loot box.
Please.
I hate this.
Just a box.
It's literally just a box.
There's a tree in the way.
Oh.
Ha!
Ten!
Alright guys, come on.
30% camouflage.
That's okay though.
That's okay.
Come on.
I just want to show you guys the box.
battle and how unfair it is it is so unfair it's absolute oh
my god he got on his knees for us bring him to his knees
snake what does hot 10 mean hot 10 means uh like progress
like uh we can continue forward the development
really don't understand why um okay oh oh okay yeah virtuous
mission okay cool cool cool i really want us to get to like
the actual because there when you get to like real virtuous
mission you can um you can see him like doing the the well
he doesn't do the flips in this which is actually a sin but
how far have you gotten it's hard to say because sometimes
when I do this I'll I'll get to um like I'll get to a boss
fight and it will be Acelot and sometimes I'll get to a boss
fight and it'll be the the fear or something I've never seen
the fury and I've never seen the end so if we get to either
of them lucky day oh no no you would think that I love this
seven it's so awesome looking in fun.
So you can kind of see it a little bit better.
It's got like big boss art.
It's really cool.
Here's, oh, boss, virtuous mission.
Oh wow, there's playing cutscenes in the back.
I just realized, oh my gosh, I never noticed that.
Are those cutscenes from, those don't look like, they're
remade.
Those look like, yeah, that's from the actual game.
What?
That's cool!
Okay, I...
Sorry, hold on.
Uh...
Oh...
The colors are so pretty.
Thank you.
Okay.
We're good, I think.
We're good.
Okay.
I have money.
Don't kick me out.
Good!
It's...
Oh!
I don't know if it makes a difference if you you can do it
out of order too but I don't know if it makes a difference
to make it like a better chance if you do it in order good
okay it's not great but we're getting good not gonna lie
having my arm out like
having my arms out floaty but like Having my arm like this
is kind of a workout.
Okay, all right, come on.
Take him out.
Never mind.
Take him out with a great, good, Tony the Tiger, he's great.
All
right, this is, okay, he's chance two, chance two.
All right, let's try and get stealth maybe.
Oh, three in a row.
Come on.
Tony the tiger buff.
No.
We're back at the beginning.
Oh!
Can you see?
Wait, you can't see.
He's got his shirt off.
I don't know why he's naked now.
He's a naked little man.
It's creepy.
Because he's a naked snake.
No, that solid snake.
I'm surprised we haven't... I haven't had the max.
It won't let me max bet, so...
Yeah, I'm eating.
Oh, I love how she calls.
She's like, hey, you eating?
No, that is not so insane.
Oh, alright guys.
We got a ration last time.
What do you think we're gonna get this time?
It's not like whenever I stop it if I can be like here and I
stop it and it'll still go to fork So here I'll here.
I'll try like on ammunition
So it's a skill issue.
No
Okay, that was it.
Oh, it's glitching again That is that's awesome.
That's not Something happening, or not something wrong with
the screen.
It's part of the game.
Is it okay?
Can you even call this a game?
You were saying...
Shh, shh.
Hush.
Oh.
Pshaw!
Oh!
Yeah!
Pshaw!
Okay.
Well, I got one at least.
Oh.
Is it just a box?
This is a game?
You think so?
It's a pay to win game.
Nothing.
No, that is not a skill issue.
Yeah.
Cool.
Come on, baby.
We are tiger stripes.
Okay, okay, come on, come on.
Come on, just a box.
Oh, chance?
Oh, Mr. It's a man.
What could it be?
I didn't.
They're looking around for me.
Trying to find me.
Oh, we're back to Sokolov.
It's just a fever dream of scenes.
Like, everything is all over the...
We're back in the woods.
What is going on?
Why did Vulcan come out?
We have no idea.
We're back at Sokolov, but he's doing his little thing.
I just don't understand.
It's all over the place.
It actually is.
Usually it doesn't take this long to get to, like, a boss or
something.
I think my luck is actually just bad today.
Oh!
Okay, we're throwing the...
What is that, magazine?
Okay.
Still just a box.
Someday.
Oh!
Today.
Right now.
Right now!
Oh, never mind.
Oh.
You're so...
Just look the other way.
All you have to do is look the opposite direction and you
would have seen...
Oh!
Thank you, Asa-Lot, for your direction.
Thank you.
basically he's saying like I thought I saw him around here
like he was definitely somewhere around here no one here
they're idiots 180 IQ not stopping this stream until she
beats the boss this is the stream you guys aren't you so oh
sorry Ocelot I was not listening to you I was not I was not
paying attention at all, I'm so sorry.
Oh, okay, here we go.
Asala is gonna get us the mystery thing because he loves
snakes so much.
Alright, Asala.
Asala, this, whatever you, whatever you decide for us will
be, will decide your true love, okay?
Okay.
Oh, crap!
Oh my god.
He knows that snake loves to eat.
Twil?
Wow.
Oh my god, he loves us for real.
You are a simp, Ocelot.
Didn't think we'd actually say that this is this thing in
action, Pokcham.
I know her.
Me too.
Oh!
What?
I don't know, Ocelot know, I don't know if like he starts
giving us direction when if he like, if the game feels bad
for us, we're not getting any wins.
And so Ocelot's like, hey, I'm coming in to help you.
Rations taste horrible, though.
I think it's better than eating a dead rat in the forest,
I'm just saying.
An uncooked rat.
Hmm?
What?
Pity poll.
Okay.
See?
I was down here and it still went to fork.
I was down here and I went to fork.
Rigged.
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh, this face.
Snake, oh my God.
Oh, no, they're starting to multiply.
Oh no, they're hanging out.
Oh gosh, it's a party.
We were not invited.
Asala, I got the rations because snake is a snack.
So true.
A fork.
Do you think he'll see us behind the tree?
Will we be spotted?
I love that they're just like, yeah, he's definitely here.
Yeah, I definitely think I saw him.
Okay, let's go, sir.
Okay.
Snow.
They're just chilling.
You guys, my luck is kind of...
Oh, hi, Sagan.
I'm okay.
He's like, how are you doing?
I'm good.
How's your condition?
Our stamina.
Oh!
Thank you.
Oh my gosh, paramedics saved us from the jungle.
Finally, we can continue forward.
Eventually, we can...
get there you just have to spend enough money obviously
finally the progress mysterious camouflage okay team okay
and there are different locations to it it's not always it's
not always this area so I wonder if we'll see that as well
last game okay let me out
Parabetic.
White girl, save me.
Save me white girl.
No!
All right.
I'm gonna press it on ration and we'll see what we get.
Oh, I pressed it on ammunition box, but it still went to
fork, okay?
Save me white.
girl oh okay oh they're we got the same thing twice in a row
that's kind of interesting yeah this is this whole thing is
Mendo please get me out of the forest please the jungles of
Russia I'm so sick of it I don't want to see the jungles of
Russia any longer please you got forked At least we have
enough words to share the single ration with awesome.
Oh, we took them out.
All right.
Got bullets!
There's jungles in Russia.
Yes, according to Metal Gear Solid 3, there are jungles in
Russia.
Isn't that the most fascinating?
Oh, it's zero.
Oh, zero.
Munda nai.
Oh, gosh.
finding tiger stripe bullet bullet okay you guys all right
okay oh oh this one's fun because we're this is the one with
the dogs so if we make it out we get to jump off the okay
come on all right all right all right let's go let's go
let's go let's go nice nice next nice nice nice the sound of
the dogs is so sad though
Let's go.
Bow bow.
Oh my god.
Please.
So love.
Can we just leave them?
We could just leave him, right?
We got the bow bow virus
Nope not yet not yet
Good dude We need more bullets
Oh, wait, I forgot this was just the one to choose the guy
Not yet.
Okay, I think you have to get it in the first try to get
great, right?
Oh, nope!
Just kidding!
I proved myself wrong again.
One last.
One last guy.
Okay.
Alright, here we go.
Alright, isn't it?
Come on.
The audio fixed.
Oh, was it out of sync before?
That's so weird.
Eyes!
Is this better now?
Oh, I'm so sorry.
I didn't realize.
I thought you meant like there was an echo in that, like,
you could hear me twice.
I didn't realize that it was, like, a delayed echo.
It was double for me when I joined.
I'm so sorry.
Oh, my gosh.
It must have been really awful to listen to.
I'm so sorry.
That's so...
Yeah, I'm so sorry about that.
It must have been so annoying to listen to me.
There's
been two times enjoying my...
Shut up!
I was hoping that I could, like, channel my energy into
that.
Look at Tiny Ocelot.
He's just so goofy looking.
Oh!
Okay, okay, okay.
Come on, Snake.
Snake.
Snake!
Don't miss!
Snake.
Snake, please.
Oh my god.
Please.
Please to God, Snake.
We need to continue.
Please, Snake.
I'm begging you.
I'm on my knees, please.
Snake!
Snake, don't miss!
Do this!
Also, you can't tell, but my credits have not gone down at
all, which is very impressive 12-hour stream let's go it
already has been an hour we haven't barely seen any of the
game you know what actually hold on hold on I think let me
try changing the game mode next time I have the option to go
to the menu let me let me try changing the game mode because
maybe being on normal It's kind of messing some stuff up.
Do you own this machine?
Hi Hannah!
Yeah, this is my this is my patchy slot machine.
It's my baby.
Hold on.
It's got to light up so we can go to it.
Thanks for the donut!
Double mint is fine, but this works too.
How much time have you spent playing this exactly?
less than you'd imagine like I'll like every so often like
you know do it or I usually turn it on when I like if I I
say when but it's really if I have company over because it's
kind of like you know it's kind of like what's the word
strange thing to have oh no the echoes back Is it better if
I just do this?
Thank you, Zero.
Is it better if I just do that?
It's worse?
Wait, way better.
What's the echo?
You guys are so weird.
I think the echo is better than that.
Okay.
I'll trust Hannah's opinion.
Hold on, I'm paying out.
There we go.
Okay.
Classic mode.
Let's change it to classic.
And now we will retry.
We will retry.
Choo!
Do you ever just get up in the middle of the night and just
go one more spin?
It's a...
There are definitely times when I am playing on it, that I'm
just like, okay, I'll end on a win.
And as you can tell, that's not easy.
I don't even think there's a true way of beating this, you
know?
Like, I don't even know if you can fight the boss.
Though I do know you can fight the four bosses, or the four,
like, you can fight the fear, the fury, the end, and the
pain.
Look at this.
We're
Oh The trees in the way oh my god take him out Have you
changed have you changed the difficulty inside?
Is there a way to do that?
I'll be honest this thing hasn't really it never came with
an instruction manual.
It came with a piece of paper So I Can you die in this if
you can do boss battles and when you die you just go back to
this area It's like the beginning, you know?
But yeah, I don't know actually how to, uh, if there's a way
to change the difficulty on the inside.
I don't know.
Load the last save.
Okay, guys.
I'm guessing key.
Key.
I'm gonna press it on ammunition.
Oh, damn.
It's actually really easy.
It takes, like, less than a minute.
If you have both keys, I can tell you how.
I do have both keys.
I do.
This is the one to open.
And then this is the one for the...
For the...
What's it called?
What's it?
Hold on.
Something key.
I don't remember.
Though, I don't want to do it right now, obviously, because
I would have to open this up.
is gonna disturb my setup.
But I would love to know how for the future, because...
Oh, never mind.
Why would you tease me?
Oh, snow!
One day.
But I kind of like...
I don't know, maybe I'm...
Oh, oh, snow again!
Didn't we...
I don't understand.
I don't.
I don't understand the mechanics.
I don't get it at all.
I don't understand why did we get snow and then we get snow
again?
What is the point of the snow?
Why do I get camouflage, but it doesn't do anything?
Why do I get camouflage?
And then when I go to, when I go to the virtuous mission, my
thing is at zero or question mark.
I don't get it.
It's so confusing.
Oh, shibata.
Nanda.
Hidden modifiers.
It has to be there, right?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
You go good now.
Don't move.
Why did X trouble disappear?
Please.
Just something happened.
Snow!
Oh my god.
Oh, oops.
What?
Animals!
70%!
We did it!
We got animals!
We got it!
Oh, what did it do?
Who knows?
Huh?
The tree.
Push?
Whoa!
I've never had to push!
What?
wait we skipped we skipped we skipped what oh my god it's
never lit up like that before so dramatic I know why did it
happen I have no idea I have no idea what's going on what's
going on okay come on all right snake get a Tony the tiger
he is right yeah that's two for two that's two for two baby
okay works every time
works every time lady look tiger he is
just wanted to let you know that i'm starting off my
birthday watching you play battle here's Slotton.
I can't imagine.
Better way to spend it.
Monica, happy birthday!
Oh my god, Azo!
Hello!
Long time, no sight.
There
we go.
Now I want frosted flakes.
Um.
I have a distinct memory of frosted flakes from like, you
know how uh, well, at like some great!
At some, uh, like hoes.
and stuff in the United States like when if they have
breakfast you can get like the little cereal boxes yeah the
mini boxes yeah I never would I never my mom never got
frosted flakes well she really never got like any kind of
like sugary cereals like that for me as a kid there was one
cereal that she would get that like I very lovingly call
cardboard O's because they just had no flavor.
I think those kind of messed me up for life because my taste
palette has been very directly influenced by cardboard O's.
So Cheerios?
No, no, no.
They were they were Cheerios from like one of those health
food stores.
Okay, come on.
Oh my gosh, you guys, I'm not feeling I don't know.
I don't know.
I'm feeling nervous.
Oh, I'm sweating.
Oh, I'm sweating snake, please, please, please, snake,
please God.
I'm not gonna look.
Open machine, turn switch under small key off, put in small
key and turn.
Turn on switch below key.
On back of door, look for red number with button behind
small plastic sliding door.
Push button to change difficulty.
One through six.
One hard easy six.
Oh my gosh.
It's so funny because I know exactly what you're talking
about with the buttons and the keys.
I'm like, oh, okay.
I know where those are.
Yes, yes.
You guys, this is so pathetic.
I finally can show you my patchy slot.
I mean, I mean, oh.
I can show you a patchy slot machine that I've had this for
a while and I've always wanted to show people and it's going
crazy.
Sorry.
There's also supposed to be a volume control.
There is.
Actually, I haven't turned much down because it usually was
very loud.
Anyway, what was I saying?
But my game, my game is camera shy.
It's getting, what's the word?
um you know when you uh do poorly when people are watching
you and uh what's that word performance anxiety yes
performance anxiety stage fright oh bullets blue ah
i mean you love metal gear so shouldn't you be thrilled for
the excuse to just keep playing it indefinitely.
So true.
Katina!
Oh my gosh, these guys are so stupid.
Snow!
Come on, animals.
For making out of the jungle with this one.
I don't, you guys, I don't think so.
Oh, oh, chance?
Wait, there, before in the background I said chance, but
this time it didn't.
So maybe the chance is on, the...
No, it's a miss.
I don't know.
What just happened?
Oh.
What?
Grozny, I know.
Oh, we get Sokolov again.
What?
This guy.
After choosing difficulty, go back to front and push, knob
down a few times until the red number turns to zero.
Just turn small key back off, and you're done.
Thank you, Dave.
I appreciate it.
We never met, but I'm happy to see you're back.
Thank you.
I hope you're here to stay.
I'm looking forward to seeing you more often.
Thank you so much.
Okay.
What do you think, guys?
What do you think?
Sokolov is very inquisitive.
Oh, my God.
Yeah.
It drives me like, you're the one burning those papers.
What do you mean you don't know what's on it?
Fork?
Cigar?
This is like, what's it called, family feud?
The board says, Cigar!
All on fork.
Well, minty fresh Kyle, it's your minty fresh day.
You better go play the lottery, buddy.
Because who would have thought we got, we would get get fork
again.
Oh my god, paramedic is so cute.
Even when she's looking at my inside, don't look.
Don't look at my pelvis.
You'll see my sciatica.
Or not my sciatica.
You'll see my scoliosis.
Oh my god, it's paramedic.
She's like, I love that curve of your spine, snake.
Bullets!
I can't work every time.
Scoliosis in your pelvis?
No!
Ooh, I like the effect it adds.
Ooh, that is so cool, right?
It's such a nice machine.
It just looks so good.
Unfortunately, mine is a little cracked up in the corner of
the snake.
You can kind of see like the the breakage a little bit.
But if I were to want to get it fixed, I would have to send
the entire thing back.
And they would have to replace this whole panel.
It would be, it's more of a pain in the ass than I'm willing
to deal with.
So, tiger, tiger, tiger, tiger.
Are you planning to buy more machines?
No, I don't need more than one, unless I get what, Metal
Gear Arcade?
I don't know if I'm that crazy, though.
Here's another trick.
There's a hidden set of patterns on the snake that tell you
when to push the buttons to get streaks.
But you can only see it if you equip the...
Stop lying to me!
Don't lie!
It's ugly.
It's ugly when you lie on the internet.
Don't tell lies.
It makes you go bald.
bald isn't ugly but if you like to have hair then it would
be kind of sad i'm just saying
oh no my hair
is the audio doubled or is it just the room uh yeah
unfortunately there's like some strange audio issues i'm
having what a what a scuff stream to have as my first actual
stream back this is so i'm so sorry
bald like sokolov so i think sokolov's i mean yeah he's a
little bald i think sokolov's bald
it's perfect stream i'm loving it you guys are just saying
that to make me feel better you're just like we can't say
bad things or else she'll she'll ghost us
oh my god the curve of your spine oh baby i don't know why
it makes him look so old or oh sorry you can't really see it
i guess um like there's it gives him like these weird smile
lines But I guess they're on a skull, huh?
I don't know, I'm a ghost, not a skeleton.
I'm a ghost, not a skeleton.
Skeleton is old mint.
It would be really fun to...
Oh my gosh, what if we find my grave and we dig me up?
Oh my gosh.
You guys, what do you think I'm buried with?
It's kind of embarrassing.
Oh my gosh, what if you dig me up and you find my skeleton?
Oh my gosh, what if you grave rob me?
What if you open up my grave and I'm just gelatinous?
Decomposing.
I love hearing you have so much fun playing with the slot
machine.
Eating Mike Tyson's bonnet, thank you!
Let's do it!
Very wormy.
Oh my gosh, we're never making it out of the Russian job and
goals, you guys.
I'm afraid to say.
I changed the game mode, but I don't think it changed
anything.
The legend.
Thank you guys for all the donations.
I really, really appreciate it.
man the myth legend uh for those who are like wondering
about um about memberships uh i don't get a monetization
until i post three videos so this is the second one and then
it says i need more watch hours too so um i guess maybe
sometime next week we'll get it hopefully I don't know I
still don't know what to do for memberships kind of I think
uh um oh sorry I was I was thinking so much and I just ended
up pressing buttons uh love you man thank you thank you uh I
um for uh cuz for memberships I I do plan on maybe doing
some streams um I'm gonna put it at like a lower tier though
because of the podcast and having the Patreon because Matara
and I will be doing some extra streams and games and things
on there so that's a little bit more of my priority so my
memberships will be probably tiered much less but yeah so I
do obviously still play to do stuff with memberships and
then there will be the emotes if you guys want that so less
than five dollars less than five dollars is what i'm
thinking yeah like either two or three dollars so make them
four forty four dollars are you crazy i thought you said
four four makes sense because obviously a spooky number but
not 44.
but yeah
Four, four, four, what a deal!
No, a simp.
We get out of the jungle when Delta releases.
Yeah, maybe the game, maybe my patchy slot is feeling like a
little insecure.
It's just like, you're gonna abandon me once Delta comes
out.
You're not gonna love this snake anymore.
You're gonna love other snake.
He's gonna be even more high death.
He looks so good though.
Oh my gosh, she looks so awesome.
Oh, you look so good.
Everybody looks so good, except Eva, sorry.
Eva in this, something about her just looks a little off.
Like her hair looks a little wiry.
Her face just looks a little off.
I don't know what it is, I don't know.
Sorry, Eva.
Grave robbing membership stream.
If we think you up and find your skeleton clutching a
suppressed H and KMK23 being a bag of cursed sad what is
this a reference to
eva my wife i love eva i think um i'm very excited to see
how she looks in delta because how i and also ocelot looks a
little weird in this too so it's not just her the two of
them look a little weird like hold on hold on hold on hold
on hold on give me the menu hold on i'm gonna pay up.
Not that it matters.
We haven't done anything.
Okay.
Um, because you can see...
No!
Get me out of here!
Okay, never mind.
Um, they have a picture of Asala, which is why I wanted to
bring up the menu.
He just looks a little goofy.
Welcome back!
Thank you!
Thank you so much.
Oh, hello, Sokolov.
How does the boss look?
She looks perfect.
Oh my god.
She looks...
Like, her and Snake?
I feel like they had the most love put into them.
I mean, the other bosses look into.
But, uh, her and...
Oh, her and Snake looks stupidly good.
They look So perfect.
I'm going to throw you into that fire.
If you don't say something else, please.
I think I'm turning into the Joker.
Oh my god, no, please.
Don't say it.
Don't you dare.
No!
There's an Umineko patchy slot for 250 right now in Nara and
you're making it really hard for me to not hit by.
That's not a bad price at all.
all i think with this patchy slot i can't i i have never
played any other patchy slot games before um oh that's well
patchy slot is true i have tried like a pachinko machine at
a convention before a long time ago and it was whatever i
don't even remember like what anime series it was if it even
was one but um i feel like a considerable amount of effort
went into wind into this one i don't know there's just a lot
going on and obviously you have like the hd graphic so it
just feels like a lot of love not love maybe that's the
wrong word a lot of something effort effort went into this
Sorry, I'm trying to choose my words carefully.
Sorry, I'm just trying to choose my words carefully.
Oh, go, go, go!
That's what I'm trying to do.
Please, let me through.
Oh, my God, finally.
Something has happened.
Oh, my God.
Please.
Let me go somewhere else.
for once.
Oh my god, I'm so tired.
Don't say it.
This is like probably the worst round we've we've gotten so
far.
If I get the chance, I'm gonna maybe change the game mode
again.
Okay, guys.
This is gonna become a meme on my channel.
Like everybody, something happens.
Nanda, this is.
All right, everybody, place your bets.
Cigar, I really want the cigar.
I don't think I know what he says when he get the cigar.
When you get the fork, he says, like, I don't need this
right now.
H&K MK23 is the Socom pistol from the game.
Are you sure you're a Metal Gear fan?
No, I knew that.
I didn't know what the bag of dirt or whatever they said
was.
I didn't know.
All right.
Sikar!
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, he says I don't need it right now.
ration he says like not bad ammunition I don't remember what
he says because I haven't gotten it enough times and cigar
and key I have no idea and then obviously the secret I have
no idea forked get forked again nerd tiger straw you guys
I'm starting to lose hope I'm starting to lose hope please a
lot my love.
Really?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, another chance.
Chance, chance.
Forked again.
I'm getting forked in the butt here, man.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, okay, come on, come on, come on, come on,
come on, come on.
Come on, come on.
Mama, Nana.
Tigers trying.
Why always fork?
I think because it's like the worst result.
Okay, what did that mean?
I don't know.
I don't know anything that goes on in this.
I literally just push buttons and I pray.
I pray something is going to happen.
Can I get the menu again, please?
Paramedic, please.
Oh!
Oh, we haven't gotten this one.
Oh, now we got caught!
Oh, no!
It's gonna go into caution after this though.
Oh.
Bullets!
Nice, nice, nice.
Nice, nice.
Nope.
Just, uh, just a tree.
Oh, the tree is in the way now.
That's what I get for...
For cosplaying a tree, he took offense.
Alright, get out of here, run away, you losers.
Oh my god, the music is so awesome.
Okay, now we're in caution.
What the hell?
I think the Umaku part is difficult.
He's so thick.
My God.
He is...
I'm so...
How thick did they have to make this tree to allow him to
stand behind it?
Like this guy.
Look at the size of him.
I can't even...
I can barely fit my fingers.
His length, like it's crazy!
Oh, dang it!
Oh, I just realized it was on.
Oh, I missed it.
We're still in caution mode.
The music is so awesome, right?
Absolute unit.
That's what I'm saying.
Snake been eating good.
Fit your fingers where?
Like a...
To...
Like a ruler, right?
What did I say?
Wait, now I'm scared.
Wait, what did I say?
Does the bottom screen do anything?
No, it's all one screen.
It's just for decoration.
So, um, but when, uh, when we get theater mode, if, if we
get theater mode, if we get theater mode, it will be on the
whole thing.
So that's really awesome.
That's when it shows like the...
It plays Snake Eater and shows like the scenes from the game
while you play.
Cross of my fingers.
Safety!
Yeah, I'm hungry.
Okay, you're not gonna do anything about it.
It's pretty cool you own something like this.
Thanks.
it to snow yeah we're picking snow in this location makes
absolute sense come on streamer look I don't think there is
I don't believe anymore I don't believe in stream streamer
look anymore I think hold on I'm gonna take a sip of your
water how
do you progress is it all random I think so I think it's all
random I see a wind coming soon psycho mantis yeah everybody
hydrate drink your water we've been sweating trying to get
these winds you know but you make sure you're hydrated too
when you're having a bad day are you more of the type of
ghost to go to the bar and drown your sorrows and booze or
the type to haunt elevators to try to lift your spirits.
Boo!
Increasing the patchy slot luck.
Thank you, thank you, Amelia.
Thank you.
Not that quiet.
Oh my God, how did you predict that?
Here he is.
He's not gonna say it though.
Never mind.
I posted it in a tweet, but I basically said you're just
gonna be getting a lot of this.
And when the exciting stuff happens, it's fun, but it is a
lot of this.
Can I please get the menu?
Please can I get the menu?
Please?
Actually, I'm gonna pay out.
Okay.
Oh wait, I'll do it after this.
If I go to the menu now...
Okay, let's try...
Wait, what are we on?
I think we're on...
Okay, we're on normal mode.
So let's try classic mode.
Again.
We tried it before.
But let's try it again.
I don't know.
Maybe it'll help a little bit.
We had a lucky streak at the start.
I know!
It started so strong!
You think that the game would just start to pity me at some
point?
Snow.
You switched into classic?
Yeah, we were on...
Oh, you were on classic.
Oh, I what?
We started on normal then moved to classic and then...
Now on classic again.
Oh, wait, so I should switch...
I should switch to normal then.
I should switch it to normal then.
Sorry, I thought I was on classic before.
Or normal before.
Try advanced.
What if it's so difficult?
So this is why when, like, some people have asked me, like,
when I say, like, oh, yeah, I have this metal gear.
Pachi slot.
People have asked me before, like, have you beaten it?
Like, and I'm like, no.
This is what I get every time.
This is what I'm dealing with.
Hi Paramount Inc.
Oh my god.
Look at the curve.
Oh, we're blue now.
Okay.
This is looking good.
Right?
This is all different.
Oh, not different.
Oh, we got some bullets.
Okay.
This is looking different.
This is looking good.
You keep getting so close.
I feel like it.
This game hates me.
Come on, please.
What?
Oh my gosh, okay.
I don't remember what this is.
And I can't read it.
I can read it, but I don't know what the,
what it means.
Someone Nihongo Jozu more than me can read it.
Someone how, someone how.
Pull out the translator.
It's too blurry?
Oh yeah, you probably can't even see it.
Oh yeah, because it's highlighted?
There you go.
I hate kanji, sorry.
Navi custom?
No, that's not the one.
Kanji is the enemy.
It's still too, but wait, no, someone, that's it.
That's good.
Try plugging your controller into the second slot.
Okay, so is it red how I thought it would be red?
But I don't understand what it means.
Okay, I'm just gonna try clicking it.
Oh my gosh, CLI.
Oh, I clicked the exit button.
Oh wait, okay, we can see.
Oh!
that's right yes it shows you the different okay so if you
get any of these combinations you get to try again and if
you I don't understand what the what the seven or three like
the Q my Samayar I don't really understand what they mean
like I guess maybe credits I don't really get it I have no
idea the odds yeah But like, I don't know.
Multipliers.
Oh, maybe.
Maybe, maybe.
Hmm, hmm, hmm.
Okay.
All right.
Oh, we're in the underground this time.
Okay.
Oh.
Yeah, just your imagination.
Just your imagination.
Yeah, yeah, you were wrong at the pier.
You're wrong.
Are you kidding me?
This is...
This is so cruel.
Oh!
This is...
This is painful.
Why are you guys even watching this?
Why are you watching my pain and my suffering and my losing?
We like pain.
Insanity is doing the same thing over.
and over and over again and never changing.
I am a simp for Metal Gear.
Nanda, this is not even the right quote.
Whatever.
It doesn't matter.
Isn't this supposed to be pay to win?
Oh, nice, Hank.
cool
Isn't this supposed to be pay to it?
Hornet stride
Very cool Yeah, take him out Okay Oh, oh never mind we are
Got demoted.
Okay guys, cigar, cigar, cigar, cigar, cigar, cigar.
Get forked.
Fork, fork, fork.
Oh,
we're red now and I don't know why.
Doesn't even matter how hard you try.
Give them my...
Okay.
Okay, okay.
Maybe the game feels bad for me now.
We're back in the underground.
Our camouflage is 30%, which is not great.
Thank you for the...
The greatest engineer of the USSR's nascent space age
looking at his own blueprints.
That's what I'm saying.
It's your...
They're your papers.
Why?
Why do you not know what it is?
Okay, all right, come on.
Come on.
Please.
What?
But I'm going through it all wrong.
If you're a ghost in your pain, does that make it the fact
pain yeah it's literally rigged oh my gosh this is this is
me can you I kind of want to see him like in the family
guide dead pose
game it's rigged I know what I've never seen that before
What?
Why did that guy just fly across the screen?
I don't know what happened.
Okay.
Wait, what?
One of those annoying guys.
Cigar, cigar, cigar!
GIF worked.
This game is so rigged.
This game is so rigged!
Nice!
Okay, that's closer to the family guy pose.
Fork and bye.
Oh!
We're progressing maybe.
Where's the jackpot?
I don't know!
I don't!
I don't know anything anymore!
I don't know!
What was that?
I've never had that before either.
What's going on?
Hi, B.
I was
so shocked he said something else.
I don't even know what he said.
Oh my god, we can finally progress.
He actually remembered.
The progress is none.
Okay, 50% camouflage.
Okay, all right.
Okay.
It's 50-50 chance, you guys.
And honestly, I'll be honest, 50-50 is never on my side.
Please.
Please, I just...
Okay, nice.
Thank you for the don't know.
Thanks for sharing your brain rot with us.
Thank you!
Okay.
Come on.
What?
What's going on!
Oh, push.
Oh, shit!
I missed it.
Sorry.
I didn't mean to curse.
No!
That was too close.
I was too slow.
Okay.
I have to look at this machine.
I can't look at...
There's a slight delay when I look at it through the
computer.
So...
Okay, goodbye.
All right.
Come on.
Oh god.
There's a timer here.
I have five.
Five.
It says last game down there.
Do something.
Yeah!
Me.
Oh my god.
Nice.
Push, push.
Oh dang.
Dang, dang, dang.
We only have two tries left though.
One more?
Uh oh.
Oh no.
One, two, three, push!
Suddenly
we're back here.
What just happened?
What?
The cliffhanger.
What just happened?
I think maybe we lost because we didn't get the helicopter.
This is the Metal Gear experience I remember.
Hope you have a good time.
Thank you.
Oh.
Oh, the jungle.
The jungle in the jungle, a mighty jungle, a lion sleeps
tonight.
It's the colonel.
I mean, not the colonel.
It's the major.
It's, wait, down here, it turned to the major.
Instead of a snake.
Why?
Wait.
I have so good fears.
Oh!
Exclamation point.
Something's...
Something is going on.
What is going on?
Me too.
I don't know.
What the hell?
Chance!
Okay.
Thank you.
Oh, okay.
Wait, what?
What's going on?
Oh, my God, please.
You guys, what's going on?
No, please.
What happened?
No.
Everything is happening all at once.
I'm so...
In the jungle, the mighty jungle.
The lion sleeps tonight.
Oh,
five, six, seven, oh, nine.
Hatay!
Let's go, okay.
The escape!
Okay, I think we can do this one, though.
We don't need camouflage.
Right?
It's, we're running for our lives.
Okay, chance, chance, chance, chance!
Nice.
Stupid dogs.
Bye-bye!
Pass a lot.
If you loved me, you'd let me go.
Oh, again?
Okay, guys.
Let's survive this time.
Yeah!
Did
the wrong order on accident?
Two, thank you!
Okay.
Nice!
Nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, okay, okay, okay.
It's okay.
We've got three chances, I guess, for the, for the, uh, for
the helicopter.
Okay.
I'm sweating, I'm sweating, I'm sweating, I'm sweating.
Nice.
Yes, yes, yes.
This is a good thing.
Oh, okay.
Come on, come on.
Come on.
Oh, okay.
One more.
Cool finger.
I'm skill issue.
You guys.
Zero, I can't do anything.
I can't...
No, there is a problem here, Snake!
Please!
We need to...
This game is hard.
I know.
It really is like so tough when I try to describe to people
like, wow, that was so cool.
When I try to describe to people like, it is not easy.
Get it?
I mean, it's just me.
I have no idea.
We're stuck in a loop.
Oh, ew.
Oh, snake thinks about his food.
Oh, a grenade!
Oh!
oh my gosh we're actually like getting stuff though this is
good right oh no not the progress please oh please oh no
i don't even know what's happening me and neither nice
i'm going to become the joker
Joker.
I think the game is actually feeling bad for me.
I think the game is actually starting to pity me a little
bit.
No more progress.
90%?
Nice.
Ooh, nice.
Okay.
We live in Apache.
Apache.
She's LaSianian.
Oh, I've never seen this guy before.
Oh!
Am I Fortnite evo day?
Wait!
What is this?
Stop.
Oh my god!
Here it is!
Yes!
Oh my god!
Bonus!
Please, please, let me get a big boss.
Please, please, please.
Oh my god, please, please, please, please.
Oh my god, bonus, bonus!
Let's go!
This is what it looks like?
It's so awesome, right?
Come on, come on, come on.
Hinaida!
Okay.
Good.
Good!
Come on, give us the great.
Oh, oh, oh, please.
Oh gosh, oh gosh, okay.
No.
I see it, I see it in there, I see it in there.
Regular opponents!
Oh!
Oh my god, look at the intros and stuff!
Isn't it so awesome?
Thank you, Iba.
See, she just looks a little off.
I don't know what it is.
There's just something.
The new eyebrows?
Maybe that's it.
Maybe.
Oh, Major Zero.
His neck here is insane.
But he looks awesome here.
Here, I'll shut up a little bit.
So yeah, you guys can hear the audio a little bit better.
But neck, I don't.
The Jinju dirty in Major Zero.
Oh my god, what he says?
He said to the...
I felt that.
Remember the basis of CQC?
I punched the slot machine.
Strong as goes, thank you!
Thank you, Asilot.
It's so cute, you get like little intros of everybody.
I love the N's Japanese voice.
I love it so much.
He just sounds like the perfect old man.
He looks so good.
Oh my gosh.
I've never actually have seen his mod.
so much his hair looks like an actual it looks he looks like
a scarecrow like it is it's so stringy sorry if the quality
is like kind of bad right now because it's like so much
flashing where's my cat my gay cat boy son patience
hopefully he comes home actually because these are random
too you don't always get the same characters.
Ow!
Yeah!
He looks so cool!
He looks so good!
Oh my god, he looks so good!
Oh, his eyes!
Oh my god, he looks so high, so...
Oh my god, I can't wait for Delta.
This bonus version music of the MGS3 is groovy!
Yeah, it's cool.
I love bonus time!
Oh?
Oh my god, he looks so good.
Oh my god, hi.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, sorry.
Oh my god, oh my god.
Nice, maybe.
Oh my gosh, sorry, I was so...
He looks so good!
Oh!
You guys, we got it!
No!
It only took...
Two hours!
Oh my god.
I'm gonna go a little slower.
so it plays as much as possible.
Oh my god.
Down here is just like so.
Ah!
Fuck you!
I'm so sorry.
That guy is my trauma.
Ah, he looks so good!
Oh my god.
This is exactly why I bought this machine.
Oh, I love that.
Oh, the walking is with the switch between the scenes.
It's so good.
Oh, man.
Someday you go through the rain.
Someday you'll be...
Sorry, I'm not even looking at chat.
I can't just, I just can't stop looking.
You look so goofy.
Oh, she looks so perfect.
Oh my god.
Oh gosh, she looks so perfect.
Oh my god, she looks so good.
Tense!
Rank?
Oh!
I don't know what that means.
Rykov looks so cool too.
Oh,
she looks good there.
And then I have repeats so that you can get all the...
all the scenes you know oh it's just it looks so good it
looks too good oh it looks too good wait i think this is a
repeat now so yeah okay all right so we got everything wait
it says last game 46 no way oh my god we have 45 more turns
yeah you know what it took us this it took us this hard to
get here We can watch it as many times as we want.
But I have to do this patchy slot part or else it doesn't
continue.
It'll end up like the music will end up fading.
It was worth it.
Oh, what did you do?
Right cough looks so cute.
It looks so cute.
Oh, what are we getting at?
Mystery!
the big bonus there is one other mode like this is the
theater one but there's Still in a dream, Snake Eater!
Yeah!
Oh yeah, it's the Luna!
Oh, sorry, I know.
Sorry, here you go.
You can see it.
I shouldn't put my hand on the screen.
So you can...
I'm like, look at it!
Isn't my machine so beautiful?
Isn't it so pretty?
Aren't the cutscenes so nice?
With my hand, like, blocking everything.
Oh, Snake looks so awesome.
Mystery!
Oh,
nice.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, okay.
Come on, come on!
Come on, shoot!
Oh, I'm so glad we got this.
Two!
Thank you!
You've surpassed even the bonus.
We award you the title, Big Bonus.
I know the big bonus came out of nowhere, you guys.
We had regular bonus, and then they awarded us Big Bonus!
Maybe the game loves us after all.
I feel like if we weren't watching you, Watching you would
smooch the screen, which is okay, I would too.
Yeah, maybe.
Maybe.
Oh, I'm sorry, I can't get over how cute Ryukawa looks.
Like, if there was a good remake, not a good one, well, if
there was a, like, a new, a re, rather, a remake of MGS2, I
guess, would Ryden look like that?
He'd be so cute.
Yeah, like a Delta remake.
Not that I, oh, oops, sorry, Osla, I wasn't paying
attention.
Not that I want that, but it's fun to see how Bryden would
maybe look.
Okay, we only have 16 left.
Look at our total get.
It's so small.
Come
on, big bucks!
Come on, big, big bonus!
Big money!
Now!
Click the link for money!
Oh, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Now you can see like the close-up of it.
It's very good.
The art is so awesome.
Oh, oh, oh.
Wait a minute.
Everyone just...
Oh, oh, oh!
Last three games,
okay.
Okay.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Okay, two more, two more.
Okay.
through the rain oh double snake dream on a tree a different
seven
last one came I
get 140 push snake it up yeah
And...
Oh, here it is.
Okay, here we go.
Oh, you can see it's the whole thing.
It looks
so good.
It looks so good.
It just looks so good.
The thing is, he doesn't flip here.
It's actually quite disappointing.
But it looks so good.
Oh my god, it looks so good.
I have to keep going real simple.
Oh my god, it looks...
Oh god, it looks incredible.
It looks...
It looks way too good.
Oh Like it almost looks like it's not a game.
It almost looks like real footage sometimes like it's kind
of scary
Graphics on a slap machine.
I know right it's crazy.
It looks so good though I think I have to keep going girls
He's just gonna fall forever Okay, all right stink.
Oh don't flip you all good he's just he's just he's
free-falling he's going for out he's he's he's okay snake
how how big is the atmosphere he's just still going out he's
okay snake we get it You can stop!
Alright!
Do something!
Pull the parachute!
Oh my god!
Snake, please!
Oh!
Okay, we need this one!
Fox is still hunting.
not still hunting.
Sorry, I didn't, oh my god.
Let's go!
Oh my god!
Time to fight, baby!
Now you're going to see how truly evil.
How truly evil!
This patchy slot game is.
you are going to see how evil this game is truly truly like
oh my god oh my god I can't believe we're here this is this
is the best and I'm glad it's Ocelot honestly I do want to
see the fury and I do want to see the end but I'm glad for
for viewing that is Ocelot you know so you You guys can see
Ocelot nice and close in this whole scene and everything.
Koi!
Yeah!
All right, oh my god.
Okay guys, prepare to lose.
To battle.
Okay, so...
All right, he has three bars.
Keep that in mind.
He has green, yellow, red.
Okay, he has three, three bars.
The tumbleweed.
Okay.
Three bars.
Oh!
See how much damage that did?
Do you see how much damage that did?
Okay.
Where are we?
It's like, you know, like, you know.
Okay.
Three bars.
Right?
And that's how much damage?
Okay.
Oh, this is my life bar.
I forgot to mention.
I have four shots.
So if he hits me four times, we start the whole game over.
okay and he has three bars do you understand why now I've
never beaten this game before do you understand I've never
beaten a boss battle ever I don't think there's a way to
heal if there is I have no idea what it is if there's a way
to heal so um
Stuck grenade?
Not bad?
Advantage?
Nice, nice, nice.
I think it would have been even better.
Why is it even already?
I think it would have been even better if we got the orange
nest.
Why does Ocelad's voice fit him so perfectly?
Oh, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Rush, rush, rush, rush.
Rush, rush, rush.
Rush, rush.
Okay.
Nice, rush, rush, rush.
Wait.
Rush.
Oh, my god.
Oh, we're back to even.
Okay.
Ooh.
We're about, we're about...
a little under 50% or rather a little over 50% for his
health.
And we still don't have any hits on us.
So that's a tumbleweed.
It's not so bad.
Okay.
Nice.
Three tumbleweeds.
A thing's going on.
Oh no.
Also, I don't.
Look at him go.
Oh my god!
Uh-oh, uh-oh, okay.
I don't know how to block attacks.
So...
Oh, oh god.
Okay, that's one hit.
Nice.
Uh, 250, oh.
What does that mean?
I'm so tense right now.
Truly the dark souls of slot machines.
Good?
Come
on, Ocelot.
Come on, Ocelot.
Ghosts are proud creatures.
Oh, no.
We didn't even attack him once.
This game is so cruel.
What's the strategy here?
I wish I could just pay more money.
Like, I don't know why it...
Why it...
I don't know why you can't like continue the fight you know
why it has to take you back to the very beginning is the
most painful part but I got to show you the scenes and we
got to a boss fight so I feel very fulfilled in what I was
able to show you guys today even though it took two hours to
get there
I don't think there's a way to avoid the attacks.
Please,
please, please!
Guys, I think we're in trouble.
I think we're in trouble.
Nice?
Ooh!
Yes!
That did some big damage.
Big damage.
Spin to win.
Nice!
Nice damage!
Good damage to win.
Ooh!
Oh!
I don't know I don't even know if I've ever gotten this far
before no second I am not daichoku please can I get it I'm
literally losing my vision I'm going unconscious I'm I think
I am I think this is it for me does money heal you no I have
max credits uh-oh uh-oh
I'm not gonna turn into the sorrow, I'm gonna turn into the
Joker.
Snake dies.
Because I'm already dead.
Your money has no power here.
Yeah, oh no, oh no.
Oh, I think it's Joker, you guys!
I think this is it!
Everybody save.
Sayonara.
You can see a snake's face in slow-mo.
Can't remember.
I don't know.
Ah.
Real footage of Minch Phantom gameplay.
Metal Gear Solid gameplay.
Haha.
Thanks, Os, a lot.
Wait, continue, though.
Like, save!
What?
What do you mean?
Whoa!
Whoa, that's crazy!
Wait, what do you mean save?
Oh, and also we're, we have our little, the little, um,
thing on.
Wait, I was gonna stop it.
I was gonna stop playing because I feel like we got, but I'm
kind of curious.
What do you mean save?
Okay, one last fork for the road, everybody.
One last fork for the road.
Ready?
Say it with me.
Get full!
Rationed!
Get...
4 big bonus why are we still here just to suffer every night
i can feel my fork in my cigar even my bullets the progress
i've lost the hours i've lost won't stop nanda codifying big
bonus what a thrill awesome why are we still here oh we got
it okay everybody's in with me oh sorry i instinctively
pushed it very quickly
I'm sorry.
Gosh, Ocelad's just hand-holding the whole time.
He won't let me press how I want to.
He's like, come on, right, right, right, right, right,
right.
Oh, Eva!
Oh, never mind.
Eva does not respond.
Yeah!
It's time to get forked!
And with that, everybody, I think, uh, I think that is all
of the Metal Gear Patchy slot.
I'm gonna keep chatting after this because I don't want to
end just quite yet.
But, um, what do you guys think?
What did you guys think?
I have no idea what's happening, but my brain liked the
sounds and colors.
Cool machining.
Thanks.
An interesting concept.
I think having a battle through slots is actually something
only...
the devil could conjure up.
I think it is so evil.
but other than that, I do like watching Ocelot spin his
guts.
I understood nothing.
You know what?
Yeah, you could watch this and be like, this is the most...
Oh my god.
This is a true...
Truly...
This is Metal Gear Solid 3.
I don't understand anything that's going on.
Will you ever do another Apache Slot stream?
Well, I think...
I think it's...
What's the word?
I'm gonna be... I think it's gonna be just exactly the same
as here.
We may be... I mean, there are still some like events that
we haven't gotten before.
will be mostly like the same exact thing.
Yeah, I'll have to check the difficulty later.
For sure.
About every two to three streams ended with a few games of
Patchy Slot.
See, that would be difficult because I had to move my Patchy
Slot.
My Patchy Slot is usually over there in my room.
And I had to very painstakingly drag it closer to my
computer so that wouldn't really work out because yeah oh I
can disable the echo mic you're right thank you there we go
so how large is it it's very large and very in charge it's
very heavy yeah it's uh okay so let's see this is my arm and
it this is the top of the machine and it doesn't even go to
like the middle and it's it's uh hold on let me measure how
thick it is thick uh maybe hold on it's like this this thick
wait it's like
You can't show these guns on YouTube.
It is kind of like a refrigerator.
Yeah, it does kind of feel like a refrigerator.
This is cool, though.
I don't think I've ever seen this before.
Or if I have, it was a long time ago.
So, yay.
Is your patchy slot running?
You better, nanda korewa.
It.
So, I would say your arm is thin, like squiggly noodles.
What do you mean by that?
Not the Joker.
One last dance for those post-game Joker, nanda korewa.
trying to figure out what we all just watched since this is
probably the most folks have seen of the patchy game.
You think so?
I don't know.
I wish I could have shown it off better, but my luck tends
to be poor, so I truly apologize, but it is quite fine.
It's not something that I could typically sit.
Well, that's not true.
I think I could typically sit and do it for oh sorry for
like an hour or something hour two if I really wanted to but
it's like so it's it's maybe not the most super duper
exciting thing right here I'm gonna actually do this
no I want to go back to well maybe it'll go maybe it will um
I don't know what to call it.
Wait, there's continue zone right here.
I don't know what that is.
I do not know.
Anyway.
Sorry if I'm making weird faces.
Sorry.
Okay.
Did you read the manual?
It didn't come with a manual!
It didn't come with a manual.
Okay, give me one second.
I'm gonna set up my real quick.
Hold on.
I'm fine.
Don't worry about me.
leave it on in the background if if we were
okay oh what the hell why am i asleep oh hold on oh what's i
get i think i did break something i think i broke my brain
wait i think i'm i think i'm oh no wait wait hold on Uh, uh,
uh, uh, uh, uh, why, woo, huh, uh, uh, uh, okay, okay.
I don't know how to work my body.
I don't know how to work my body, you guys.
Maybe I should, can you guys hear the machine still?
I'm gonna put on some music.
Let's see.
A little.
You can hear the birds chirping just a tiny bit.
Key.
Do.
Very springtime.
I use this BGM all the time.
You're a simp.
Thanks for showing off your pouchy slot machine and for all
the work it took to set this up.
Stream has been really special.
Special is a word for it, isn't it?
That is a word for it, right?
Maybe you're supposed to ignore the 1, 2, 3 and risk it for
the biscuit.
I don't know.
Why would they tell you?
to one two three then oh snake you good that always seemed
to get you blues or yellows which I think are the lowest
value spins maybe I don't know what's the fork count at
truly unforkable measures is this your craziest metal gear
item probably the other thing I kind of wanted to show it
off in the background but but I couldn't fix it in a good
way was my, I have a snake standy, like a life size.
Well, maybe not life size, but I have like a big snake
standy from when they sold, what was it?
I think it was MGS, I can't remember actually.
It was one of the advertisements in Europe though.
I think, I'm pretty sure it was MGS too.
but like what's the what's the oh my gosh my brain is is I
have a lack of ectoplasm happening is the standing bigger
than you no no no no
I can say that was the best VTuber playing a patchy slot
stream I've ever seen.
You must watch those a lot, truly.
You must watch those all the time.
It's a big market.
Everybody out here is saying, VTubers playing patchy slots.
It's the new, the new meta.
There was some, oh, I'm gonna zoom in a little bit more.
some uh i did want to like um what's the word uh i wanted to
talk some more about like my hashtags and stuff like that i
know it's kind of probably not the right stream to do that
but um even i was i was like at first i was like i don't
need an art tag whatever but then um i think i need an art
tag i feel really sad leaving my old tags and stuff and then
i also kind of want to talk about like um fan names sorry
it's like the most random time to talk about this isn't it
but um oh and if you haven't seen
oh where is it my schedule for well tomorrow tomorrow i'm
playing zoom beanies
Oh gosh, my voice is, my throat is still healing, so I can't
do high notes right now, but, um, uh, yeah, but, um, on, uh,
Tuesday I'm playing the new Chilazar game, because I'm a
VTuber, you guys, and I have to play it, I have to, I'm so
sorry, but also, I kind of like those, like, games where
it's, like, find the, anomaly I think those are kind of fun
it's mandatory I can't say that I'm truly been resummoned
until I play it you know and then Monday is the podcast
release day so instead of a stream you can listen to the
podcast probably pretty much every Monday I'll have off just
because that's when we'll be releasing the podcast so um yes
yes yes uh wednesday is when we record the podcast so i'll
have that day too and uh thursday is facade which is a game
that i've i saw a video on it recently and i was like oh my
gosh i forgot this existed um there's like this other old
flash game i think on new grounds called I think it was like
The Negotiator or something.
And it always...
I don't know if it's the same person.
It's a classic.
It is, yeah.
So, The Negotiator.
Yeah, you guys remember it?
Oh my god.
I reference it all the time.
And I don't think people realize...
Anytime...
Well, like...
I'll be like, I'm gonna blow this place to hell.
That's what I'm referencing.
Oh man So silly And then on Friday Tomodachi Live I was
thinking maybe we can make Like a bunch of silly characters
Of course like Snake Or we can We'll have you guys decide We
can make like whatever silly characters we want And just
have them in And then Saturday Metal Gear Saturdays snakes
um i say metal gear saturdays i mean we might go after twin
snakes we might go into like acid um because i have not
played acid yet though thank you for the thank you thank you
so much
um hi mint quick reminder it's not a day off if you work
that day hope this helps Oh I don't I mean
But it's I don't consider it You know It's like
Memberships will be open on Tuesday right?
I have no idea That's up to YouTube It's not up to me Hi Vid
Hi Thank you for the Akatoto Thank you How do I say Wait,
wait.
Osos, thank you.
G-Nuko, thank you.
Kune!
Oh my gosh, long time no see.
100 plus player Tetrio win.
You're a super...
Metal Gear Twin Snakes, let's go.
I remember spoiled myself by accident one time with this
game.
I can't wait.
I can't wait to play Twin Snakes.
And then probably Sunday, I'll do a gorilla stream.
Honestly, I just didn't know what to stream that day, so I
said gorilla stream if I come up with something.
Maybe it's Tetrio, but I'll be honest, you guys.
I haven't gotten better at all at Tetris.
I haven't...
Thank you for all the donuts.
Thank you, guys.
I haven't gotten better at all at Tetris.
I...
I'm going to get my butt white whooped.
You're awesome.
You're
awesome.
Thank you.
Oh gosh.
Glad to have finally gotten the definitive MGS3 experience.
Thanks, Mint.
This stream was definitely more fun than you seem to think.
I'm glad that you say that, Sam.
Thank you.
Oh, gosh.
Sorry, girl, but there's at least one minute.
Mint Tomo?
Mint Tomo!
What is that?
That won't wipe your Inno's top.
Thanks for all the donuts!
Thank you guys!
I'm vacuuming your butt for that comment.
No!
Don't do it, Jimmy!
To the heroes of Tetris for the privilege to wipe your butt
and body.
I don't want you to stop this.
No!
Oh man!
Why?
Why is my brain like this?
Thank you!
Mint brain, don't say wiped.
Don't say wiped, absolutely.
Do not say wiped.
Mint mouth, wiped.
Oh, stinky.
Choo!
Cool piece of Metal Gear franchise you showed off today.
Thanks for the stream.
I'm the new being haunted.
Yay!
Yeah, all it requires is giving me a little bit of your life
force.
Is that okay?
Batayfun.
I can't believe I got this invested over watching someone
play slots.
It got a little intense sometimes, for real.
It got pretty intense in some sections.
I was feeling the pressure, the actual pressure.
Unrelated, but I really love your Ace Combat games
collection.
Thank you non-John Ace Combat.
I'm so jealous that you have even older Ace Combat, though.
I only have PS2 era, sadly.
I've gone to so many used game stores.
Unfortunately, so many of the ones that I have are in those
like GameStop-esque boxes.
but um you know i i only played seven and when i did i was
like oh my gosh i think i i think i love this and i i
struggled a little bit with like following the story so it
almost felt hold on i can't say wait it felt like if i were
to have played metal gear rising before the rest to the
Metal Gear series.
You know what I mean?
So it's like, I really wanted to know more about the, the,
the rest of, uh, the lore.
that's nuts.
I know, right?
Who would do that?
Go ahead.
Play the games in release order, idiot.
So yeah, I've just been kind of collecting them.
um i haven't played a lot i've played any of them yet so
excited excited jpeg dog lore yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah seven
is a new story but knowing the well i think it was like i i
know it all takes place uh what's it called um it takes
place like you know more about like the belkin war and stuff
like that um like there's obviously there's uh like there's
a lot of lore that didn't feel um like you know uh what was
it stonehenge and everything like that strange reel yes yes
it all takes place in strange reel yeah yeah yeah it's it's
from three right that it takes place in strange reel or four
wait i can't remember three or four right it's four wait
from two i thought one and two were like kind of mostly
separate is that not the case am i misunderstood don't worry
i still have my membu card if you open memberships back i'll
be joining back thank you
well.
Yo, I really enjoyed the stream today.
Thank you, Mike Tyson's butt.
I hope your butt gets thoroughly wiped in a good way.
In a good way, right?
It likes weird games where the stories doesn't make much
sense without context and that focuses on machines is this
time to pitch armored core i'm scared to play armored core
because it's like dark souls robots and dark souls scares me
but typically i don't like to back down from a challenge so
hmm hmm hmm hmm
thank you for the stream for sharing the machine i've not
seen such an extensive look at it before and man what could
have been with the fox engine remake i know when you get the
theater mode sometimes like i said before when um before it
started playing with the bonus or whatever like sometimes it
will let you choose theater mode or there's there is another
mode i think the other mode takes you directly into the like
the quote-unquote story part of the game so I think it
starts you on the helicopter but with this we got both so I
guess it worked out honestly but Yeah, seeing the cutscenes,
just...
Oh, hello.
Monkey!
Oh,
ape escape, yeah, we gotta do ape escape.
Miso gear.
Yeah!
Yeah, mint is adorable.
Stop it.
stop come on guys stop it come on come on i mean i mean it's
like i'm amazed like i have to be cute right but like come
on oh
okay let's talk let's talk fan names in this very okay sorry
i should have done this last stream i just My brain, I'm too
silly, okay.
And hashtags.
And I hope that, uh...
I know that probably if we're, like, older fans, um, I don't
necessarily want to get rid of the name fandom, right?
I don't want to like throw away everything that we came up
with before but I do think that having something a little
bit more concrete because you can't say I am a fandom you
have to it's more like I'm part of the fandom you know what
I mean I think boot ties boot ties like bow tie but a boo
tie fandom is good
boomers boo champs I don't know I haven't really thought of
it at all because I kind of just came in thinking that I
would have everything the same as before so I'm just like
I think Boomer's...
Chocominto art?
Wait, that's so cute, actually.
I think...
I think Boomer's feels a little too...
Like, any ghost vtuber could have that, right?
As their fan name.
I think we gotta come up with something a little more
specific.
There was wisps before.
Like it was Fandom and then...
If you were in the Fandom, you were a wisp.
But, um...
Hmm...
Phantoms?
Phantoms in the Fandom?
Like this?
Phantoms?
Insane in the membrane?
Phantoms in the Fandom?
Phantom?
Phantoms?
Mint Busters?
That's kind of cute, actually.
Wait, mint.
Mint?
Oh, mint Busters.
Uh.
Fantomies?
It's kind of cute, too.
It's pretty cute, too.
Hmm.
I'm seeing if I see any others that I really like.
Thank you for this.
Oh no.
Mentos.
Oh my god.
This page seems to have some instructions in a forum for the
Metal Gear Pack.
What?
Really?
Since our time was cut short, what are the chances of a
return to trials and tribulations to play the Maid Cafe?
Wait, that's a DLC, isn't it?
Um, we'll see.
We'll see.
I can't just play the DLC episode.
I have to play everything all over again.
Dead cell.
Oh, dead cell.
That doesn't even make any sense.
Like it, I...
I kind of love it, but...
I know I want everything to be a Metal Gear reference, you
guys.
Yeah, but not everything can be a Metal Gear reference.
Boots?
I don't get it.
Oh, like, dudes?
I'm not feeling it.
Sorry.
I highly recommend keeping everything the same.
with the mods as wasps and us as membus.
Well, membus is the membership though.
In the leech room, while watching Mint attempt the boss in
Sonic for the 11th time.
Okay, shut up, Pune.
See, and part of me wants to keep things the same as before
two, but like, We have to be honest, things aren't the same,
you know?
Things are a little different than they were before.
Can we just keep whips?
But you don't want anything, you don't want something
more...
specific?
To...
Me?
I'm so, I'm so egotistical.
It has to be related to me, you guys, I'm just kidding.
Mint Tomo?
Boo-Boo-Rigade.
Oh, like, Brigade.
But Boo-Rigade.
This is all...
I think, no matter what I choose, I can't make everybody
happy.
So I think I just gotta choose what I like the most.
Because...
It'll still be.
Like, if it's...
You know, it's...
Hmm.
You are awesome.
Min...
Min-T-Mintos...
Min-Mintus...
S-Sotans.
Oh!
Min-Tis-Sotans!
Like a Minnesotan?
like the state in the United States of America Minnesota
that's wild why
that's actually crazy uh oh I think my chat froze are you
guys still there oh okay it froze on YouTube YouTube has
been freezing so much for me recently I don't know if you
said this before but our weekend stream always early the
upcoming weekday streams are a bit too late to catch for me
unfortunately ah ah I didn't say before weekend streams I
typically do a little bit earlier but also in the weekday
I'll try and do some midday stuff as well so there will be a
mix of stuff and my schedule is never truly consistent
unfortunately i'm sorry i'm all over the place but uh but
there will be times that will be good for um eu watchers if
there are any as well so yeah sorry that i don't have a i
don't think i've ever had really a set time where i'm just
like okay guys every day 7 p.m est catch me here no i'm
Sometimes, I don't know why.
Sometimes I'll be like, today's 7.
But tomorrow is 6.
I don't know why.
It's maybe just because I try to do a little bit of variety
for people who are just like, oh, I can't make the 7 p.m.
times.
I can only do the 6 p.m.
So, yeah.
I'm fine with whatever you choose.
Can I get some of that dripping chocolate?
I feel uncomfortable.
Hold on, I'm going to try and reset my
YouTube.
There we go.
Thank you.
You mentioned let's go.
Okay.
The fan cheese?
Wait, that's so cute, actually.
I'm kind of leaning towards phantomies.
Ugh.
Because it sounds close enough to fandom.
Phantomo?
No.
I think Phantomis maybe.
Because it's like Phantomis in the...
See for me when I say like, hey I'm a wisp, it doesn't feel
to me so much like a like like it just feels like a
description like you guys are wisps but like you're you're a
phantomy wisp i think right like it's more like i'm i'm my
wisp type is phantomy and memberships are the
So I think we'll go with phantomies if you guys are okay
with it.
Phantomies in the fandom.
For those who still like fandom, of course you can still use
it.
Of course, of course.
Okay, it's been decided.
I lay down the hammer.
Okay.
I feel so...
I don't know.
I don't know how to feel.
Like, I feel so...
What's the word?
Maybe...
not like it's like almost guilt you know it almost feels
like like a guilt but don't think that you know because
we're making a few little changes you know there sometimes
this happens to other vtubers as well where they have to
change their fan names for whatever reason so um will they
be redesigned what the wisp design no no it's Still the
same.
I don't mind.
Okay, thank you, Splagoon.
I don't know, I just got so many questions from people being
like, what's, what, what do I call myself?
And like, I think, you know, like I said back then, we came
up with stuff, but it was kind of like multiple things.
I think we need to settle on some more definitive stuff.
You know what I mean?
Something a little, like, I don't know.
Wisps is still fine, but...
I don't know.
Am I overthinking this?
Maybe I'm overthinking this.
I don't know.
Am I...
Yes?
Should we just give it as...
Should we just...
Then should we just keep it as a whips?
Whip, whips, whips.
What do I do?
Pull?
Okay, pull.
I don't want this responsibility.
Fan name.
Whips.
I don't want this responsibility.
You decide.
If you don't like the poll result, then you know what answer
you really want.
That's true.
You're us.
I just don't want people mad at me.
I just don't want people being like, oh no, she's changed
too much.
I don't know.
Maybe I'm overthinking it.
Can't please everyone.
Yeah, I know.
I know, I know, I know, I know.
And I know this is probably not even like that big of a
deal.
It's just a fandom.
It was because I get so confused when it's like You have the
wisps, you have the fandom, you have the members, you have
this, you have that And I'm like, I can't keep up either I
can't keep up either Ugh
Okay.
Well, Fantomies seems to have the consensus.
Not by much.
I will give it that.
And not everybody watching.
Oh.
There's more votes coming in.
I was gonna say not everybody watching is voting.
Hey guys.
I'm just kidding.
You don't have to vote.
It's okay.
Oh.
More votes coming in.
Thank you.
I'll just keep it up.
Well, we'll keep this up.
And then we can decide hashtags.
Flip the W and rearrange the letters.
And you have what we really are.
Simps.
Stop.
No!
Okay.
You're a simp.
um um okay hashtag so I need an art tag what was that I like
the chocolate mint art that was cute I have to make sure no
one's using stuff though um I guess we can keep my current
one as like it's still a general tag that's even written as
that so I can still keep it as that too um toothpaste
toothpaste Why?
No, we're not.
Why you guys have to say...
Fant...
Mmm.
Mint paste.
Simps rise up.
The will of the wisps is phantomies.
stop saying fart stop stop it stop saying fart stop it stop
ghost can't even fart you guys this is not even accurate
stop saying
stop saying fart please not with that attitude
Ghosts are all far?
What are you talking about?
What is ectoplasm?
It's like a little more gooey.
Ghost post?
Oh my gosh, wait.
Hashtag ghost.
But it doesn't have to do with art.
I think that's the hardest thing.
It's probably also taken.
Snake's just been...
I think Snake is lost.
I can't find his way through.
the forest at all
fan art oh that's kind of cute like that wait that's
actually so cute wait that's wait it's probably taken let's
check let's check let's check There's like some yaoi parry.
I don't think I can use this.
There's like some yaoi parry.
Oh my god, these get a little graphic.
It's just some guys.
I don't think I can take...
I don't think I can use it.
I know what we'll fix it
I wonder if this is actually We just do fan fart It works
Wait I have to see if this is taken Yes Yes Yes
Phantography?
Wait, that's so cute too.
This is what you wanted, isn't it?
I feel like this is probably taken, but we can check.
It's hard being a ghost.
Because there's uh so many other ghosts oh this one doesn't
seem to be used very much
maybe oh with a with an f like that
mintography you guys are going crazy
phantom paint this one's a little punny right it's kind of
fun
yeah this one wait latest this one doesn't seem to be used
at all well a little bit but you know it's hard to find a
hashtag that's not used at all and you know what this kind
of fits in with the theme of the general hashtag since it's
which is spirit photography that's what it means in Japanese
mint sightings wait that's so cute too I like that for like
if you ever like well I don't well if you get like the merch
and you like take a picture of me somewhere but I guess that
works with the Shinday Shashin too you can probably use the
other hashtag for it.
NSFW tag!
I like fan-tography though, I think that's good.
I think we can go with that.
I think we'll go with the fan-tography.
Do I...
Do I have to...
Why are you so fast with that?
Maybe it's necessary.
I don't know.
So that certain things don't show up in the fan-tography.
Only fans!
Oh my god.
Like this?
Like that?
I feel like that has to be taken, though, right?
Yan!
Please know R18.
Is this $100 enough?
At least maybe any R18 is untagged.
The fact that you donated!
Akadono for that!
Also, OnlyFans is definitely taken.
Do not...
I don't want to look at it.
I'm just afraid that if people draw stuff, that they'll put
it in the art tag and then it'll show up mainstream.
Not safe for mint.
No!
I don't think having a tag necessarily...
necessarily encourages it.
It's just so that it, if it does show up, it's in its own
place.
I think.
I don't, I, I don't know.
Maybe we don't need it.
I don't know.
Not everyone has one, so it's not so necessary.
Oh.
Oh, I think you're in the rain!
I'll think about this one.
I will think about this one.
I feel weird about it.
I don't know.
Especially with people just coming in.
Especially with people just cupping it up like Let's just
get this off the screen real quick
I think I have the live tag Minto Live And I have the
general tag And I have the art tag I think that's good
enough I think that's good enough Anything other Like if
it's not art You can put it in the general tag And I think
it'll be okay Hmm cosplay tag I don't think I need one I
really don't think I need one I think you could put cosplay
in the general tag because I'll still check it when you have
so many hashtags it's hard to check all of them so yeah
memes and general tag yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah just put it
all in the general tag unless it's art because for art like
I like to you know obviously I go through it for for um like
thumbnails and stuff like that so so we'll have art live is
minto minto live as it has been always
Boston makes me feel good I think think that is probably
already used so much.
I do like not save for mint though.
I think that's really funny.
My keyboard no do JP copy and paste.
Copy and paste.
I think probably you could do it in if you wanted to, but...
mintolive I wonder.
The last thing...
Oh, sorry.
I was like, you guys, I think I'm stupid.
Oh, it's mint olive!
I searched hashtag mintolive, and it I clicked latest and it
was a soap and it said mint and rosemary and I was like mint
that's me even though I searched even though even though I
searched mint myself first time here and love the MGS3
gotcha experience thank you thanks for being here
Oh, man.
But also, it's mint and rosemary extra virgin olive oil
soap.
I was like, mint olive is the hashtag.
Hashtag mint olive.
That's so funny.
Mint olive.
But yeah, okay.
Those can be the hashtags.
Um, and then.
Uh.
Yes.
Fantomies is still winning, but it's.
it went down a little
I still don't know what to do maybe I'll sleep on it I'll
sleep on it and I'll make a tweet about it so that we can we
can maybe I'll ask Google I'll say I'll give it you know
I'll spin a wheel but I'll make a tweet about all this being
like here's hashtags it's just these three and here's a fan
name and yeah yeah we'll see
ask Matara for her opinion as well yeah maybe I will because
uh she I tend to ask her for like her opinion on things a
lot too anything else you wanted to discuss with us no you
are dismissed class is dismissed no no I just wanted to hang
out too you know I feel like since I've gotten back I mean
last stream maybe I didn't talk so much it was like me
answering things and then singing so it was less talking
with Tara Miller
that's perfect because that means um that means she will die
maybe by my hands after I finish sucking her soul you know
soul sucker yummy yummy are you big boss venom or Ocelot?
Ah.
Well, it was never explicitly said that Ocelot...
Was it?
Actually, I can't remember.
No, I don't think it was explicitly said.
Right?
It was explicitly said that Ocelot killed Master Miller?
Kazuhairo Miller?
What are we supposed to call your cat these days?
How do you know I have a Oh my gosh, I'm going to try and
give my cat a friend this month.
It was never explicit.
It was explicit.
It was implied.
Yeah, I think it was implied, but it was never like, Hi, my
name is Asala and I'm going to go to that house and I'm
going to murder him in the dark.
No, it was a little bit like, yeah, we'll see each other
again.
Um, oh, my cat.
That guy is stinky.
Oh, my gosh.
He...
Uh, let's see.
Hmm.
Stinky.
He's very stinky, my cat.
He's kind of the worst.
Huff, huff.
Don't have him.
He's dark.
He went outside and he rolled in the dirt today.
And all the pollen.
But, oh my gosh, it was kind of crazy.
Because I had gotten my cat shaved a long time ago now.
I got him shaved because his hair was getting really long
and matted and stuff like that.
So it was like forming knots on his chest.
He couldn't reach it.
and stuff and so i shaved him and after i shaved him he was
he was like super scraggly for the longest time like his
hair just was not growing back he uh he had like some
patches grow back but like overall his hair was just like he
looked like a old grandpa Did he look like a sphinx cat?
No, because he still had hair growing.
It just was not a lot.
It was, like, really ugly and terrible.
It was, like, it would, like, stick up.
It was just so bad.
But when I came back from Japan, he had so much of his hair
grew back.
I was, like, all it took was me leaving for him to become a
regular cat again.
And he's, like, really soft now.
And I'm like, ah.
I can finally pet you again without feeling disgusting.
I was stressing him out.
Probably because every day I'm just like, Grow!
Grow!
And he's like, don't put pressure on me.
Why are you so mean?
I say it lovingly, okay?
I say it lovingly.
He was stressed he would shave him again.
It might have actually like really freaked him out.
But I mean, having the knots gone was really important
because that hurts.
That hurts him.
So, yeah.
Hair tonic with the nip.
Hi, Minto.
Thank you for the fun stream.
Fun fact, cat nip is in the plant family as mint.
Really?
Is that why you guys are so addicted to me?
Obsessed.
You guys are obsessed with me.
The awkward in-between phase applies in for other species.
Yeah, I felt like he was going through a strange puberty.
But he's all good now.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, he's all good now.
It's not, his hair's not as fluffy as before, but that's
fine, because if it were, then it would be getting nodded
again.
So, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Maybe we need to add cat ears to the wisp design.
Maybe we need to, um...
Yeah.
You're a simp.
I hope to see you out.
I would love to show you my Ace Combat merch with you
though.
Oh my gosh, yes!
Wait.
Do you have a lot?
It might be a lot to bring, right?
Okay.
My...
Do you have a friend in mind?
No.
I do not.
But basically, like yesterday, I decided it.
I was like, okay, this month is going to be the month.
I have to get him a friend this month.
I don't know why.
like it's I've been trying to get him a friend for a really
long time so I
think I'm gonna stick with wisps I think I just decided
because I've already said wisps several times now are you
still thinking about this sorry I'm an overthinker.
Okay.
Get out of here.
I like Fantomies too, but...
I have an idea.
Actually, I don't know if I'll have my old settings for...
memberships.
Greatest anime betrayal.
Yeah, I think Wisps...
I can be like, you guys are my little wisps.
It's simple enough that it's fine.
Even though it's like just a regular word.
But that's okay.
It's okay.
Do both?
No, no, no.
I think that's why I was so conflicted to begin with.
Because I already had multiple stuff.
It's like calling cats.
Whisp-s-s-s-s-s-s-s-s-s-s-s-s-s-s-s-s-s-s-s-s-s.
Whisp-s-s-s-s-s.
Oh my gosh, it's perfect.
And we can put cat ears on you guys for real!
Oh my god.
It's perfect!
Now I feel so much better.
Wisps, zps, zps, zps, zps.
My cat's looking here now.
Zp, zp, zp, zp, zp, zp, zp, zp, zp.
No.
Yeah, it's perfect.
So cute.
For your YouTube kittens.
Come here, my little YouTube kitten.
What is that noise?
What?
Oh my god.
Not safe for work, Takami.
NSF Wisps.
Wait, that's kind of funny too.
I'll think about it We'll think about it I'll think about it
I'll think about it
Hold on
I just realized I had a message
Do you know what you're going to make your member icons Or
do you already have one?
I already have stuff I'm hoping that YouTube will has saved
my old stuff.
I think I still have it though.
From before.
But I'm hoping that they saved it.
So that like when I turn monetization back on.
It's all like the same.
Otherwise it's going to be a little annoying I think.
I don't trust YouTube.
You know what?
I don't know if I do either.
be wiped if that's the case uh wait like where even is my
okay wait emotes okay i have my emotes i don't know where my
i don't know where the membership like tier pictures are
maybe i don't have those anymore uh oh but i still have my
emotes if you guys want to see them um they're quite old so
they're they're quite old so they're of like my older model
but I have this one PN PN PN PN I have this one doya doya
your soup fan name is Wisp no ghosticles stop cease cease
Cease!
Doya!
I have this one?
Yeah!
Jinzo!
Ta-ta-ta-ta-ta!
Ta-ta!
I
have...
I have...
Oh god!
Wait.
I have...
What is that?
A master has...
A master has gone outside.
I don't remember what...
I have...
And I have...
Wait, this is just...
This is literally...
This is, this is just...
Oh, but opposite.
See, some things truly never change.
Can I bite my lip?
Hold on.
I think I can...
Oh wait.
Hold on.
Aub.
Ow.
Wait.
No, I'm just smiling.
I'm just smiling.
You're aup.
Oh!
Will we get chili mint back for during Halloween?
Maybe.
If I'm feeling spicy.
Um, yeah.
Chili mint.
Struggles to bite lip.
Mm-hmm.
I thought I could bite my lip.
No, I'm just smiling.
I'm just smiling.
Oh, well.
Yeah, and then, um...
I had some more that Emory did.
But I don't know where they are.
Maybe they're in a hidden folder.
I have almost everything So I'm working on a newer version
They'll be done Wait no Actually Are you sure?
Oh and if anybody wants it This is the old one My old
headband There you go
It's like nothing has changed
Yay Oh wait hold on I can actually Oh gosh VTube studio oh
my gosh Wait I can I can I can I can One second I can Um No
Here Put a on you guys?
You want it on?
I lost my Ahoye because I'm not an idiot.
Let's see.
Oh, wait.
I don't know how to...
I don't...
Oh,
wait.
Oh, wait.
P, Q, R.
There, I found that.
It's kind of...
It works a little bit.
We're matching!
We're matching.
Wait, maybe I might make it a little bit bigger.
I don't know how to turn it.
Wait, how can I turn it?
Is there a way to turn it?
Uh-huh.
I don't know how to turn it.
This works.
I guess.
Yippee!
Slay system.
Slay control.
Oh, I got it.
Thank you.
That actually worked.
There we go.
It's a little bit better.
Aha!
so cute extra lacy yeah extra lacy and it's got my old ghost
new ghost this is you this one right here well not you
exactly is he moving on his own oh i think he's actually a
ghost I think
he's actually a ghost.
No, there's a... hold on.
I have a... I have the wisp.
I have the wisp design still.
Uh...
Hold on.
Please hold!
Please hold.
Wait, it's somewhere.
Where did I save it?
Why can't I find anything?
Ever.
Why am I so unorganized?
Holding?
Yes.
Hold, hold, hold.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh!
Maya, I hope it's okay if I show these.
This is so long ago.
Oh my gosh.
So...
Yes, of course.
Okay, so the left is what I drew.
What kind of outfit I was thinking.
For those who don't know, Maya actually helped come up with
the way I look now for my second outfit.
So she actually came up with it.
So this right here.
This little guy there is you.
That one right there.
That one on my right.
Yeah.
So.
I'm so grateful to Maya because...
She gave me like so many, like I sent her my ugly, stupid
poopy drawing and she made it look so perfect and cute.
I was so happy.
Needs cat ears stat.
Yeah, we'll add cat ears too.
So you can be whipspspspspsps.
Yeah.
She made everything look so perfect and cute.
There were so many designs that here I...
Is it okay if I show...
I don't know if I ever showed these books.
before i don't i can't remember to be honest um i think uh i
sent feel free to okay thank you i love you i love you maya
looking forward to the mint organizes her hard drive stream
yeah for real so i gave oh these two oh gosh the left one is
so cringe i can't my art is so bad oh god okay don't look at
it but she gave me so many variations Like, look at all
these hair styles and dress styles.
And I think I ultimately settled on 10, as you can tell.
But there's so many.
I also really like 6.
I think it's so cute.
So, yeah.
So, so many.
But definitely, Three, three is really cute.
Five is really, wait, I think five and...
Oh no, five and six are just a little different.
Those are longer.
But I ended up really loving the wavy hair.
So, yeah.
Six had the old hairstyle.
Uh, a little.
It's just, uh, it's, yeah, it's my old hairstyle, but with
the twin tails on the sides.
Mm-mm.
And, uh, it's kind of similar to this one.
And then I drew two with like the little hair sticking out.
And yeah, one day I'll grow my hair out eventually.
The wavy hair was so last minute, so I'm glad you liked it
the most.
Thank you.
You're a genius, Maya, you're a genius.
Little hair pokies.
long hair mint maybe who knows can ghost even grow longer oh
go can ghost hair even grow yeah of course i just have to um
you know i just have to consume more light force and then uh
do you wear wigs will you wear wigs yeah just have to
consume more life force and then yeah easy peasy increase
the ectoplasm exactly exactly so maybe one day we'll see we
shall see
us Momo already offered ourselves once we could do it again
I know when when Matara said that she was getting Momos to
sacrifice themselves to summon me I was like wow I'm
feasting my friend Rifticus is I remember Rifticus is
bawling over that there are no ponytails not yet not with
that attitude gosh are we tasty momos
yeah yeah the momos were delicious you're us
thank you for the dono she hates us
But yeah, it still feels very weird to be here.
It feels very strange.
But that's okay.
I'll get used to it, I'm sure.
And hopefully, hopefully you guys stick around.
We can all hang out still and, you know, have a good time.
and hopefully you guys enjoy the podcast and I simp oh wait,
sorry, I was reading I realized I was reading that last dono
but I'd never said it out loud I can honestly oh my gosh,
thank you for all the donos I can honestly already imagine
the fan art you floating in a moonlit night in the middle of
a forest with my cat ears wait, I don't have the cat ears,
you have the cat ears surrounded by dozens of different
colored glowing whiskers with your own cat ears whiskers Oh,
with our own cat ears.
Maybe even tails.
Like slime rancher.
The Momo Wisp path seems like it works.
Tara gets to eat the body and mint the soul.
Yeah.
It's a parasocial relationship.
Cashing in some life force for twin tails.
Can we get Hime cut twin tails?
Oh my gosh.
um oh sorry yes symbiotic relationship a paranormal
relationship
parasitic relationship my my last um outfit was a little um
was a little uh what's the word
um it was it was meant to be a he may cut i wonder if that
came across kind of it was it was he may cut but with short
hair but maybe it didn't come across as a he may cut i'm not
sure i've saved so much money while you were gone oh no keep
saving cat tails is glow sticks what you're like waving your
tails around that's kind of crazy
My last outfit here or in heaven?
Oh, my last outfit here.
This one.
Jump scare.
It's so funny.
She came out of nowhere.
Oh my god.
Oh, old, old, old men.
jump scare what are you what what what what are you doing
here I thought I thought I killed you why are you here what
do you want what do you want old mint funny old but yeah I
was supposed to I don't know, you can kind of maybe tell
that it's a he may cut.
Mint 1.0, my beloved.
Yeah, jump scare.
She's the old mint, but she's from the past.
So doesn't that make you the old mint?
Wait.
She's the old mint.
I'm confused.
I heard someone mentioned my obsession with ponytails.
Ponytail mint win.
I don't know.
I have to first even see if I'm staying and get a new outfit
then.
If all of that.
One step at a time.
one step at a time though if I get a new outfit I already
have an idea
yeah uh
anonymous thanks for the donation do you still have that so
I was a French maid who fell in love with the prince and I
got killed in the 14th century Yeah, my very extravagant
lore.
My very extravagant lore.
It's what turned me into a vengeful ghost, you know?
But, I don't know.
Maybe I was exaggerating a little bit.
I couldn't possibly get close with a prince.
I don't know.
Is that a light novel?
I was a French maid and I fell in love with a prince, but I
ended up dying in the 14th century.
And now I'm a ghost, destined to search the afterlife for
all of eternity.
Vengeful?
Yeah, I'm a vengeful ghost.
I've always have been.
I've always been a you day.
I guess we could put the cat ears on if it's for you.
Put your cat ears on.
Meow for me, kitten.
Meow for me kitten.
Meow.
I may have missed it, but what is your cat's name?
Boo taro.
How do you feel about fan-made or fan-commissioned live 2D
or 3D models?
If you want to!
Oh my gosh, though.
That's like...
That's like a lot though, isn't it?
Stinky.
Butaro.
That's the first thing that came up in my brain.
Kind of like, butaiaro!
Because it's so stinky.
But he's also Boo Tarot.
Boo Tarot.
So, so, so, so.
Boo.
Yeah, like boo.
Yeah.
Sir stinks a lot.
Boruto's dad.
You're a student.
Don't worry, the game I want isn't on sale yet so I can
spare this.
Welcome back, Minto Phantom from the Made Mid channel.
Thanks, Gonzalia!
It's been a while.
Hello.
Yeah.
Play the Ghostbusters game PS3.
Why is it any good?
Is it something you suggest?
I can't wait for Zoom Beanie's tomorrow.
Zoom Beanie's was maybe...
So as a kid, I only played like a handful of those Edgium
Attainment games, right?
And one was Zoom Beanie's.
That was my favorite.
And the other one was Freddy Fish in the Haunted
Schoolhouse.
Out of like those like Freddy Fish in the...
There's the car.
And then there's like that one kid that looks like Danny
Phantom.
But out of like that whole...
Edumotainment Cinematic Universe.
I only owned that one single Freddy Fish haunted
schoolhouse.
Pajama Sam!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
A Puppet.
See, I don't know their names because I never owned the
games.
I only knew Freddy Fish.
And only because I was interested because it was a game
about a haunted schoolhouse.
I was like...
He's just like me!
I was like, oh my gosh.
I'm rooting for the ghost, baby.
But, um...
Yeah, so I would play that all the time, and I would play
Zumbini's all the time.
Like, I've played...
I can probably quote more Zumbini's than I think is healthy.
Welcome back, boys.
Thank you for the Akadata.
Thank you!
Could you get close to a prince?
if they were a cute girl, or if they were a hot old man.
Hi.
Where?
What?
I was saying, like, if I'm a maid, there's not a way I'm
going to get close to a prince.
They're so princely, you know?
Sounds like a webtoon, though.
Sounds like a webtoon, I might even read.
I used to have the littlest creature games.
And the Wishbone one.
I don't know those ones.
I don't know if you're familiar with either, but Wishbone
was my favorite thing.
Wishbone was the dog, the detective dog, right?
I watched it a little bit.
Fleens.
You're not fleens.
Well, whatever you are, make me a pizza.
Yes!
Oh my gosh, I love the pizza guy.
I love when he goes, more toppings!
be i'm gonna be so obnoxious tomorrow i'm really sorry i'm
gonna be so awful tomorrow i'm gonna be
oh my gosh yes so beaties so will we let's go i'm so excited
i've i've been wanting to play zoom beaties on stream for
like three years so i'm like it's my favorite edge of a
table game from a kids from when i was a kid i was so
excited when i was a wee wisp oh my gosh welcome back we
miss you while you were in heaven oh my gosh beast hot boy
hello oh my gosh thank you so much yes oh Oh my gosh, you
can play anything now.
I know.
It's actually the freedom.
It's kind of overwhelming where I'm just like when I was
trying to when I was making like thinking of the schedule
for for next week.
I was like.
Like I don't maybe I shouldn't like just start off with all
the things that I wanted to play.
But in the end I kind of did that.
now what changed and heaven you know it's a little bit
strict because you know you got to follow those heavenly
rules all those you know you got to be a good pure soul so
Zumbini's was not good and pure apparently
more topping but question do you prefer hot dog or pizza
probably pizza yeah probably pizza
oh my gosh zoom beanies
and then the narrator he's just like Like, the Zumbinis are
off.
The Zumbinis are going to the promised land.
The Zumbinis, I don't, why, why are they going there?
I don't even know.
Fatal Frame, Ace Attorney waiting room.
Maybe we will play Ace Attorney again.
We can do some of the newer ones.
oh geez stop spoiling the game okay i'm so sorry i'm so
sorry oh my gosh oh i can't wait to play zoom babies isn't
it weird that i'm this excited about it is it strange that
i'm just like let's go children's game but i just loved it
oh my actually my favorite quote from the pizza guy and I
quote this almost daily is There's something on that I don't
like Yeah Oh my gosh It's so funny
Thank you Can't wait to see Play older Ace Combat Yeah I
can't wait to play that too So much So much we can do dude
oh my gosh and honestly i'm really super duper excited about
the podcast because besides the metal gear episode there is
one episode that i think um may surprise some people and
would be like what so i'm that's something that we're that
we're cooking so i'm just kind of like actually i mean we're
cooking several things but something in particular that i
believe we can you know really do so i'm just like
so um super we're excited with the stuff with the podcast
it's just kind of an exciting time like i'm you know happy
to be back and i'm happy to be uh able to do so much with
you guys so
yeah yeah yeah Oh.
Yeah, that one.
That episode.
I can't even say when it will be out because I have no idea.
We have a sort of plan.
This game sounds super familiar.
Did you know if this game was ever part of a real arcade?
I don't know.
Also, speaking of real arcade, please play Granny in
Paradise some days.
It's about an old lady rescuing her cats.
It's 10 out of 10.
I will look into that.
Thank you.
You are a simp.
Thank you, welcome back.
Thank you.
Ghostbusters PS3 360M is really good and has all four
original Ghostbusters actors reunited for one last time.
No way, really?
So after Ghostbusters 2, it's basically Ghostbusters 3
before we actually got more Ghostbusters.
What?
Wait, that's actually so awesome.
It's really good.
Hi, Mintel, how's it going?
I'm good.
Thanks for stopping by.
Have you played Devil May Cry before?
I haven't.
We can play that too.
Minta, I don't mean to alarm you, but I'm starting to worry
that Snake isn't going to find his way out of the jungle.
Part of me is worried.
What if it, like, you know how, like, if you leave a screen
on for so long, like, that image will burn into the screen?
I'm, like, concerned about that a little.
I really wanted to get to, like, the...
I really...
Oh, we got forked again.
I really wanted to get to the...
Oh my god, we got...
What?
Um, again.
Wow, both in a row.
That's in...
Ah!
Did you see my hand?
No, you didn't.
Um, you saw nothing.
You saw nothing.
Anyway.
Shut up, Sokolov!
This isn't about you!
She manifested this because I think I got some energy from
Zumbini's.
So I was able to, you know, partially have a physical form.
Not physical, but like a, how do you say?
a uh what is it called oh my gosh i don't even know my own
ghost terminology um yeah corp corporeal an apparition yeah
yeah yeah
i wonder how do i get back to demo mode oh i think oh i know
why it's because Because I have all these credits.
I have to get rid of the credits first.
But I'm like stuck at 50.
I see you now.
I moved all of my stuff around.
I'll just do stuff while we're talking.
Don't mind the background, okay?
Don't mind the background.
ground.
What the?
Again?
Okay, hold on.
Maybe we can beat this one this time.
Maybe we can beat.
Maybe I can beat this one this time.
Nice.
Oh, Jose.
What are the chances of getting that I think I'm stuck on
credits forever I think the game just said yeah you know
what you will get unlimited money you don't have to pay can
you imagine if this happened in the actual thing like in the
actual arcade if you just could play forever she's so wait
did I come on what are the odds of If it's 50-50, I'm gonna
pull my hair out.
It can't be 50-50.
It has to be more, right?
Look at him go.
Oh!
Sorry.
I'm so sorry.
Oh my god!
I screamed.
I'm so sorry.
Now we have hints.
Now we have hints on how to be Ocelot?
Are you kidding me?
Now there's hints?
Sorry guys, I'm so sorry.
I'm so sorry.
I didn't think I was gonna win.
It didn't mean to hurt your ears.
I'm so sorry.
Wait, we're back at Ocelot though.
Oh my god, wait.
Wait.
I can only like understand a little bit.
I think they want me to continue.
Advantage.
Okay, yeah, the rush.
Choo!
Thank you!
Audio doko?
Oh, I turned it down.
There we go, is that better?
Great!
What is happening?
What is going on?
I have a safety zone now!
Oh my god.
What is happening?
Oh, they're getting the save data, so that's what I'm doing
while it's like retrieving the save data.
I was like, hello, am I gonna go into the bite?
No way.
Oh my god.
Highway to the safety zone.
Oh my god, we're
back where we were before.
Absolutely insane.
I don't have my stuff set up, so I'm sorry that it keeps
freezing.
Hold on.
I'm gonna, like, go down here so it doesn't look as weird,
maybe.
He has less HP!
Yeah!
Oh my gosh.
Okay, guys.
This is...
This...
This is how we'll end the stream.
And we have the safety zone!
Nice.
Yes.
You know what?
I will.
Nice.
Oh, that did a good amount.
Wait, my safety zone is going down.
Why is it going down?
Uh-oh.
This is...
Do it, Palpatine boys.
Palpatine.
Oh.
He's like, he talks a lot.
He's just excited, Snake.
He's just really excited.
Oh my gosh, thank you for the Haku-Toro!
Damn, X, thank you!
Glad we have cat ears now.
I think we needed that extra pair of ears.
I'm so sorry, I feel really bad for real.
I feel so bad.
Oh, he's shooting!
But because we have the safety zone...
Oh!
Yes, my God.
Oh, my God.
I don't...
Oh, I hope we get another rush.
Oh, yes!
Oh, my God!
Yes!
Rush, rush, rush!
Oh, my God.
Oh, my God!
Wait, you guys.
This is... This is...
No way, no way, no way, no way.
Oh, I'm getting my hopes up.
No, no, no.
I'm not gonna get my hopes up.
oh my god oh my god oh my god i'm gonna i'm not gonna i'm
not gonna i'm not gonna oh
my god wait wait wait wait wait oh my god oh my
god did you see the amount of damage oh that just did
because we're happy we have the advantage okay we're back to
even though oh my god this is insane oh my god no way
another crash another rush no
no no no no way this is happening oh my god
oh my god I'm gonna cry This is so crazy!
Oh, oh!
Come on, Snake!
Oh, here they come, the bees!
Oh!
He found us.
Oh my god, thank you for the donation!
Oh my god!
Awesome!
Oh my gosh, Pig!
Thank you for that, Katoya!
You're really back, I'm out of the country right now, so I
can't watch too often, but here's a donut!
Thank you!
It's not as much as I used to do, but it should cover the
three years of membership if you would let that continue.
Okay, and now it's time to enjoy some of our face.
Thank you!
I'm back!
He's Sashiburi!
Sorry.
Oh my gosh.
Yeah!
Oh!
That's what the... It says to push.
It said push, so I pushed it.
I paused it.
I can't believe we clutch that, you guys.
I cannot believe.
Wait, so now, are we going to be in the forest, or...
Oh, my God.
We're in a new area.
I'm going to cry.
We're talking to you.
and she's just she's just talking streamer look for real oh
my god this is a first this is an absolute first for me this
is an app this is an absolute first for me oh my god and
it's still just is I still have unlimited credits the music
is so epic why is it so cool we're just walking through the
forest but it's a different forest it's a different forest
it's a different forest it's a different jungle I was here!
I was here!
Oh, the end!
Oh my god, wait!
Are we going to fight the end?
No way.
Wait, remember how I said, if you were here, I said earlier
at the beginning of the stream, I've never seen the end,
I've never seen his fight before in this.
So I'm like, yo, I wanted to see...
Oh, what the...
Oh!
Nice!
Good job, Snake.
Oh!
What is going on?
What is actually happening?
What is happening?
CQC time?
Yo!
Hold on, let me, uh, do this too.
I'm gonna end the poll.
Do you think the first part was like the tutorial?
No.
Right!
Oh?
Oh, come on.
What?
Oh, what?
Okay.
I didn't get the boss fight, but, you know, I got 30 Gs.
Let me fight!
Okay, wait, wait.
We have to keep fighting these guys.
We have to keep CQCing.
And getting so many Kodakos.
it calls.
Thank you!
You're pretty good.
Let me fight.
Let me... Let me fight!
Let me fight!
Hello, Sagan.
I don't like you.
I don't like paramedic either anymore.
I don't like any of those guys anymore, but you know.
Let me fight.
I went
from heaven explosion sector.
Very friendly to ghosts.
Let me fight.
We're so good at CQC, guys.
We're still like the best ever.
We've walked so much.
Look at it, we keep getting straight walking.
We're just walking, walking, walking.
We're a walking crew.
I'm bloodthirsty.
I'm just flipping all these guys.
They never see it.
Never see it coming!
Come on, hold on, Paramount.
Oh, oh, I need a tip.
To battle.
Keep going.
She's got a taste for blood.
Oh, I did it out of order, but that's okay.
Is it double audio?
Yeah.
Sorry, I do that.
I have a...
So sorry that it's a little distracting.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, hello.
Hello, sorrow.
Cheers!
No.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, don't put me back here, please.
No, God, please.
Please, God, no.
Oh, okay.
Oh.
I don't know what this means.
So there's, like, things written here on these buttons on
the walkie-talkie here.
It says Trans Saver is the first one that's green.
The second one is Sensor Sotar, but it's red.
And the third one is Emergency.
see, but it's green.
Oh!
What's going on?
I can't say I know what it is.
Oh!
Big boss time?
No!
Oh, wait, he's saying new things now.
Okay, I think we're still in.
I think we're still good.
God, how long do people just sit here and play this to be
able to get to this?
this far.
Endless circle of.
We just gotta keep getting through the woods.
Back to flipping guys, yeah.
More tips.
Yeah, but like, it's like, yeah, I get the, so it's like, I
get it, but it's just like, how do I, it says the tips, like
the colors are being, like you'll get the better stuff based
on the color, but I'm like, how do I get the colors?
Huh?
How do I get the, you know?
Like they don't, they act like it's not just pure luck.
And also, this thing is rigged as hell!
I keep getting the same thing over and over again.
Like...
Skill issue.
Yeah, basically.
Oh, now we have the sensor, but we don't have the trans- Oh,
wait, the trans...
The trans saver is blinking.
Interesting.
I don't know why it's blinking like that, but now he just
said that- Oh!
Oh, now we have the sensor too.
Oh, cool.
Thank you!
I usually just lurk, but I can't stay long, so when I wish
you an amazing day, thank you for being a fantastic person
and for the amazing time, why is it your name?
Thank you!
Your- your- your name is so crazy.
S-L-I-D-3-3-F-E-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B.
Thank you.
Fox?
Fox!
Oh, I wonder if the transceiver goes red when we're using
the codec.
Hmm, hmm, hmm, hmm, maybe.
Okay, please.
Alright, snake.
Oh.
Okay, keep going.
Gotta head to bed.
Good night.
Don't worry.
I don't want to see if we get to the boss, bad.
If I lose the next one, then we'll call it quits.
You know?
I just want to try one more time.
Fox.
Okay.
Alright guys.
Two!
Three!
First movement!
Oh my god!
It's the actual game!
It's the actual game cutscene!
Oh my god.
Boss.
Win!
Can't believe you use your goose.
skills to grab a hold of luck.
This is...
Oh my god, the music?
Did you know there's actually a soundtrack for the Patchy
Slot.
So, uh...
If you like any of the versions of these songs, you can
actually get the CD for it.
I don't own it yet.
But after this song... Oh, it's...
It's so good.
Maybe I'll get it.
Okay, so I have... Big Boss time is 8 out of 30.
Okay, that's what it says.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
Remember the album!
Ah!
This is so ISO.
I don't know what's going on, to be honest, but it's kind of
fun to see the scenes.
Yo!
This is so ISO.
I'm so into this now.
It's 60s on!
Big payout.
Big money, baby!
Boss plot being like, what are you doing?
Don't be so crazy!
It's interesting that these scenes are from...
I guess they just didn't have maybe...
I don't know if it's the timing, but they didn't get to...
Fox engine.
Okay, we only have three more.
Oh.
Thank you!
I have my... my Hidari from Miki memorized now.
Thanks.
Thanks for the Japanese- Japanese-Josu listen!
And don't forget the manaka.
Manaka, the manaka.
I didn't think anyone would get this far.
Me either!
Oh my gosh!
Last?
Oh my gosh, look at them.
They look so good.
Oh my god.
Look at them.
They look so amazing.
Oh, I've never seen this visual before.
Oh my gosh.
See the whole like codex set up on it?
Like this is so cool.
Oh my gosh, I've never seen this visual before.
Yo, they look so cute together.
Wow!
Oh my god, you can't see, but the exclamation point on the
side here is also lighting up Rainbow.
Second movement!
Oh my god!
Wait, this is awesome.
Oh my, you guys.
No way.
But also, why is this also...
From the... This is also original cutscene!
I thought I was under the impression that the whole thing
was Fox Engine.
Solid time?
Wait, what is this saying at the bottom here?
Oh my gosh, that's my favorite part about Metal Gear Solid
when he says, It's solid time!
Do you guys know this song?
Why is this song?
Oh, sorry.
But I was under the impression everything was Fox Engine
made, so...
This is the most unexpected development imaginable at the
end of this stream.
No, this doesn't sound like Donna Burke.
This is amazing!
Why is this song?
Okay, I'm definitely buying the soundtrack now.
I feel like crying.
It was so beautiful.
It's so beautiful.
Oh, we can do this and do it again.
Because we still have...
We have 40 out of 60.
Go ahead and...
This song goes hard.
It does!
I did not expect this to happen at all.
I'm so shocked.
This is so...
I'm so happy this happens for the first time on stream.
I can't believe.
Oh my god.
Sorry.
I feel like there might be people who will watch this, just
wanting to know more about the patchy slot.
And we'll just hear my obnoxious, like, screeching, my
Banshee screeching and my...
Annoying commentary.
Scissors.
Okay, I'm gonna be quiet so we can get more of the song.
I love this.
It's so good!
Sasuke got Metal Gear.
No matter what kind of Metal Gear it is, it has amazing
music.
Even as Apache Slot.
I need this song!
Oh my gosh.
Oh my god.
It's just so worth everything.
Oh, so thank you for the don't know.
Don't worry, this is the exact experience is what I was
hoping for tonight.
Man, the most obscure original Metal Gear song.
Correct me if I'm wrong.
Like, I don't recognize this song.
So, oh, it's over.
But if it's Apache slot exclusive, that's like insane.
Title is become the big boss second movement and seems to be
Apache slot original.
No way.
Oh my gosh.
Where are we now?
Sound force?
I don't wanna stop now.
This is like a cutscene.
Oh my god, I literally, I put my, like, I, I gasped and,
like, put my hand over my mouth.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, oh my god,
oh my god.
Oh, I just want to hear him say the, like, uh, what, what,
he says, uh, like, uh, oh, he's like, Sene, what he said,
I'm sorry, my brain is, like, literally melting right now
because I'm like the way he says like the snort like oh I'm
dying sorry I'm like actually oh my god I can't think oh my
god the bird
how does this fight work though this is the same as Ocelots
I'm sorry I'm like actually losing Oh my god!
Oh my god!
Thank you for the doughnuts, you guys!
Singer's name is apparently Sa- Sa- how do you say that
though?
I don't even know Apache Slot Soundtracks were a thing till
now, but like adding it to your collection, Min!
Thank you, Pinkerton!
Watching Min picking MGS and Apache slot history with this
stream.
Okay.
Oh, here here here here.
Here here.
Heavy!
Oh my god!
Oh I get goosebumps every time!
Every time!
Oh my god!
Oh!
Sorry.
I'm like...
I'm not reading all this.
Wait.
I think I actually...
Okay, wait.
Oh, okay.
It's saying that I can like...
I can like pause by pressing push and I can skip the movies.
We're fine, we're fine.
I don't need, oh, one, okay.
This is just what to read.
It says like, while you're waiting, read this or whatever.
We have one more thing to do until we get the new armor.
Okay, we're good, we're good, we're good.
Okay.
Oh my God, oh my God!
Oh my God!
Oh, he's so leafy.
How do I still have 50 credits?
Oh my god.
We're finally at the end fight.
Oh my gosh.
It's the end, guys.
Time to leave.
Also, I've noticed that there are two more.
Have you guys seen that there's two more slots?
I wonder if you can fight the boss and if she's all five.
I wonder I wonder I wonder Just skip the pain.
Yeah, that's the that's the funny thing it was I fought the
pain before but like in a Like it just skips around
sometimes, but the end And the fury I've never done so I'm
thinking
Oh my god, watch out snake you're just standing there just
as a sitting dog.
What are we doing there standing man, I'm only Oh, you look
so...
The bird looks so cute.
Oh my god, your arm is showing out!
Snake, don't just stand!
They're like an idiot!
This guy's so dumb!
Ouch!
I was adjusting and I was like, you know when you're like,
oh, out.
Like you catch your fingernail and like lift it up.
Bro is confused.
He's just... Bro is just as stunned as I am.
He's just like, I get here?
He was just like literally an hour ago or two hours ago.
I was just I was just listening to Sokolov like repeat the
same phrase over and over.
I was walking through the same forest for two hours.
How did I get here?
I don't know how far I want to go with this because I just
noticed the time and I've been streaming a little longer
than I intended to, which is fine because I'm having so much
fun.
Snake T posing the end.
The bottom screen is so cool.
Also, no more mini-snakes.
Yeah, you're right!
He is gone!
Also, for those who haven't seen, it is one big screen.
So it just kind of like, in this part, it just kind of like
fades.
You know, it's just like a fade effect.
But it's really cool that it's like one big thing.
Uh-oh.
Wait, our safety zone!
Our safety zone!
Thank you for the suit- Oh, sorry.
Thank you for the dono.
Also, do you own the machine?
I do own this machine, yes.
This is my own personal machine.
So I don't have to pay.
I feel like this fight will take even way longer than Ocelot
so maybe maybe we'll die before I uh before we get to do
anything um yeah so I don't have to I have like a little
button down here that gives me unlimited uh or not unlimited
but I can just press it and give me as many credits as I
want as I want so I don't have to spend money on this i
already spent enough money to to buy it so
i'm getting really bad luck it's really cool hearing snake
talk so much though
he's listening
He's asleep!
Come on!
Yes!
Searching?
Battle mode searching?
Oh my god, it's so cool.
This way, this way.
Oh no!
No, no, no, we had it!
This one's tough.
But he's not shooting me either.
But I'm out of the safe zone.
Uh-oh.
Thank you for the dono.
Imagine dropping a save and coming back two weeks later to
see the head defeated, but Apache's lot more?
I know that'd be crazy, right?
Uh-oh.
Oh, Snake, why are you just standing there, you big old
dummy?
No, Snake, please!
Uh-oh.
Oh!
Oh, God.
Oh.
He's so dumb sometimes.
I don't think...
Honestly, we might get a save on this, but...
I feel like we're just gonna end up dying.
If we die, though, I wonder if it will take us back to the
very beginning?
Or back to like this area, you know what I mean?
I wonder.
He tanked that.
Oh, again?
So soon?
Oh!
Hemio Oh my gosh Snake You're not He attacked so soon We
didn't even have a chance Oh Come on Search Search Snake
Search Use your eyes Thermal goggles Thermal goggles Why
does he hit If you roll matches though I don't think there's
a way to Unless you get like a perk.
I have no idea.
I wonder if there's like a very very specific match that
like matchup that you have to get because but it's also
rigged.
It's not letting me get anything to avoid it unless it's
this one let's see.
Never mind.
Lock on, lock on, lock on.
Come on, Snake!
Oh!
I can't!
Whoa!
That does big damage!
Oh!
More, more, more!
More, more!
Oh!
Oof.
Big damage though.
Uh-oh, is this the end for us?
Ha, get it?
The end.
Is this it?
Snake.
Ah!
Oh!
You.
You!
Slippery!
You slippery snake, you!
Good, good.
Oh,
yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, see the footprints!
Oh, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes!
Okay, okay, search, search, search, search, search.
Oh, no.
We lost him.
It's okay.
ghostly heart.
I'm my I think my blood pressure right now is kind of insane
because I'm so like like so happy and so like shocked and so
nervous oh no snake snake
Okay, here is where we figure out, here is where we learn if
we start over from the very beginning or if the game is a
little, if the game is a little, uh, what's the word?
A little kind to us.
Three week long gambling sequence.
Oh!
Jesus, that- and Bogan!
I didn't even, for some reason, I didn't even consider
fighting him either.
It did save!
Yo.
I think we're back at the beginning.
Yep.
We got to get boss time again, I think.
Okay, are we going to get forked?
Let's get forked one last time, you guys.
Get forked!
Rashed him down.
Oh, wait, no, no, no.
I just want to go to him walking around again.
Okay, there we go.
All right.
Alrighty, guys.
Well, that was an intense run.
That was kind of insane.
That was that was a lot that was so much holy cow holy cow I
did I I said that I really wanted to see the end battle and
I got to and I just wanted to show you guys the theater mode
and I got to I got to show you guys Ocelot battle and I I
got to show you how cruel it is, and then I got to show you
how we beat it.
Oh my God.
That was so intense.
Secret song too, yes, the song, the original Patchy Slot
song.
I'm gonna go listen to it after this.
Oh, oh.
Tomorrow is Zumbinis.
You're a soup.
Thank you!
What insane luck for you to be able to beat us a lot, enter
a new area, discover Apache slot exclusive OSD, and face the
end on your first Apache slot stream.
This has been so much fun and happy to see you having tons
of fun.
Thank you, man.
Thank you!
Thank you so much.
Whoa.
Oh, hold on.
Let me turn off the echo.
Sorry.
There we go.
I feel so fulfilled right now.
I can't, how are you supposed to, like, okay, obviously,
obviously, like, it's saved.
But, how are you supposed to, like, continue and actually
beat it?
I'm so curious about every inner workings of this machine.
There's still so much that I don't know.
It's so fascinating.
So much fun.
What a purchase?
Konami emusement card?
No, there's nowhere to like tap it.
Not that I can see.
Choo!
What the?
Pachi Slot was actually so much fun to see.
Thank you for the stream.
Welcome back.
Thank you.
What's the stream meant?
Will you be doing it?
MGS karaoke.
If so, don't forget to add a new song in.
like to do an MGS karaoke.
There's not a ton of songs I can sing, but a while back I
made a mint Minecraft skin.
Totally not because I wanted to cope.
Wait, I have a question.
Is it this one?
Oh, that's so tiny.
Like a while back, like how long while back?
This is from
October 31st, 2020.
Wow, Halloween.
It's another one?
Okay.
Just posting the tag again here.
So I can see it.
I want to play Minecraft.
But I'm trying to figure out how to.
Because I want to maybe play.
in like a Minecraft server with maybe like other wisps but
um well probably membo's like probably you need to be a
membo to gain access to it but Minecraft doesn't let you um
uh it's part of their like or rather it's against their
rules to play it like under a paywall so I wouldn't be able
to play Minecraft in members so it's kind of like I don't
know yet.
Playing single player, I guess we could always do that too.
There is, of course, always that.
Yes, yes, yes.
Don't we own the server?
What server?
The non-existent, there is no server.
It's completely non-existent.
I have, I have to, I have to buy Minecraft.
I have to buy Minecraft, first of all.
So, I gotta do that first.
I don't have it yet.
Yeah, yeah.
You're a simp.
Vic Boss, you're pretty good with this patchy slot.
Thank you!
Mint love, thank you!
Generally, I never thought I'd have so much fun watching
someone play patchy slot for five hours.
Thanks for the stream and welcome back, Mint.
So much!
Thank you, thank you.
Really, really appreciate it.
Yes, yes.
A server without a nation.
Lots of people have Patreon servers.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I don't know if Matara would be interested in doing a
Patreon one.
Because, first of all, the Patreon will only be for...
the podcast length so once the podcast is up you're a kind
of dead server that wouldn't be so good and so if I am
staying longer after the the podcast of course it would be
good to have something that I control skin posted on the tag
thanks for the skin tag I'll see you played with the Ryusei
Nova in a whore.
That is true.
I did play once.
Wait, then do I own it?
Wait!
Do I own Minecraft?
That's so true.
I did...
I might have Minecraft.
I actually...
Okay.
Okay, I vaguely remember...
Wait, uh-oh, I might be in trouble though.
I vaguely remember...
Okay, this is all coming back to me right now at this very
moment.
I kept getting emails...
In my mint email being like, Hey, don't forget to migrate
your Minecraft over to Microsoft account.
And I was like, I'll do that later.
I...
I never did it.
So...
It's gone now?
Wait, but...
But I bought it.
So...
If I just remake the account...
Wait.
Wait, so I have to buy Minecraft a third time?
No way.
Okay.
Okay, I'll buy it.
I swear so many people own Minecraft multiple times.
Why?
I bought it, though.
I mean, I guess it is my fault.
They did warn me.
They did send me a lot of emails.
Minecraft.
No, Takis!
Oh, no.
Stop!
No Minecraft funds.
Thank you.
Number servers are fairly common and it would be pretty
cool, I think.
Haha.
Not that I like Minecraft or anything.
You forgot to add an extra haha at the end of that.
Haha.
I feel like by now, probably someone took Mint Phantom.
so what am i i have to come up with a new username i have to
come up with a new username we'll think of something we'd
love a member server yeah maybe we can do that member server
but i would play um not on members obviously but normal
mint phantom fps vtuber reel that sounds like a That sounds
like a name that someone who shits themselves would take,
you know?
I don't want that kind of image.
True.
Anyway, I had a lot of fun today.
I hope you guys did too.
Thank you so much.
I'm sorry that...
It took five hours to get to the really exciting bits, but I
had so much fun and I hear seething in the universe.
Do you?
I'm unbothered.
Couldn't be me.
Oh, but yeah, I had so much fun.
fun um thank you guys for watching and uh see you tomorrow
for zoom bini
okay you know actually i realized this um yesterday or not
yesterday well yes yesterday but like after um the karaoke
stream i think because i went from karaoke or from singing
the last song to ending it like you know i used to end my
streams with playing boston So, but I'm kind of also afraid
of the content, whatever police con, you know, especially
because I still have a strike on my account.
But I think maybe, maybe I can do it.
I don't know.
I'm kind of afraid of the, yeah, the content ID.
Because actually my, my bust in cover is even.
have a strike but it is partially blocked according to it i
don't even know where where is it partially blocked let's
see where are you blocked
oh it's been partially blocked in some countries and their
regions yeah but where it doesn't tell me where I have no
idea.
Oh well.
How old of a block?
Long, long time ago.
And I never got, I never got like, even in the past when I,
when I would play Bustin, I never got like content ID'd.
But I feel like maybe YouTube's stuff has changed a little
bit in the past three years.
I think you're good as long as you don't watch another, We
say video.
Oh my gosh.
We talked about that, Matara and I in the latest Patreon, in
the next Patreon episode.
We looked up some of those spy animals and how terrifying
they are.
Just singing Acapella.
Okay.
I wonder.
Wait, do I still have my instrumental of it?
Maybe somewhere, right?
Maybe somewhere.
Oh, wait.
This is the mix.
Oh, I do still have it.
I'll just say.
Sing it myself!
Can you hear it?
Oh, it's kind of quiet.
Definitely.
Why is it in one ear?
It's like so in one ear.
If there's something strange, sleeping in your bed.
Let me tell you something.
If there's something weird, sleeping in, why is it only in
my right ear?
Ow!
Let me tell you something.
Busting makes me feel good.
Busting, busting, busting, busting, busting, busting,
busting, busting, busting, busting, busting, busting,
busting, busting, busting, busting.
Never seeing things sleeping in your bed.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, an invisible man sleeping in your
bed.
Let me tell you something.
Ow!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Bustin, bustin, bustin, bustin, bustin, bustin, bustin,
bustin, bustin, bustin, bustin, bustin, bustin, bustin,
bustin, bustin, bustin bustin, bustin, bustin, bustin
bustin, bustin bustin bustin, bustin bustin, bustin bustin
bustin bustin, bustin bustin bustin bustin bustin bustin
bustin bust Feel good, feel good, feel good.
Freaky ghost baby.
Freaky ghost man.
Freaky man baby.
Wait, when does the next part start?
If you're all alone, let me sleep in your bed.
Phew!
Shoo!
Sleep.
I am afraid of no bed.
I think?
An invisible bed!
Freaking ghost bed!
Yeah!
Bust it!
Bust!
Feel good, feel good, feel good, feel good, yeah, yeah.
Bustin, Bustin, Bustin, Bustin, Bustin, Bustin, Bustin,
Bustin, Bustin, Bustin,
Bustin, Bustin, oh, oh, oh, wait, hold on, I have it on
loop.
Thank you guys.
Otsu Minto!
Otsu Minto.
Otsu Burstu.
Otsu Burstu Minto.
Go to Burstu Minto.
Go to the gym, Bye-bye.
Oh my god.
Oh, I forgot to tell you guys.
Okay.
I have this crazy story.
Well, I'm going to tell it to you real quick.
So anyway.